[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
round
what's going on
i see a lot of y'all in there already
hustling motivate what's going on
wondering dutch what's going on gerald
mack what's going on
[Music]
no doubt
[Music]
[Music]
oscar emilio a gonzalez full government
out here what's going on ranger fair yes
the legendary jason ryan will be in the
building christopher hart was going on
yo i see y'all connor what's up i like
this one kanoa ramen noodles
salute you know what i'm saying and let
me get on these super chats right quick
what's up
shout out to jason for making the best
console ever will we see more fps boost
games in the future hoping for ac
syndicate the lords are the best no
doubt we're going to talk about fps
boost fuzzy i already got you brother
good morning everyone my xbox series s
console curious as to when dvr will
receive an update so many great games
and awesome moments to share yeah we
definitely going to talk about that you
know we're definitely going to get into
that good stuff we're going to chase it
up in here we'll get
king solved the whole realm
talk to the people right quick
again what's going on
these levels sound great
sound fantastic so uh yeah we will be
back we'll get the legend up in here and
uh see y'all in a little bit
fun show y'all
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we with messaging people don't aim
check my vocals follow on twitter but
i'm anti-social my city but i'm still by
coastal
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled but i'm gonna be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you ain't gotta say it
i'm embarrassed for you always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
that's
[Music]
a proclamation
[Music]
i'ma just chill and watch so many snacks
in the attic i wanted to chill with the
pack and be like a young wolf but then
they would mistake me for addict if i
can imagine it's cool to give you some
advice and invite your girl to your
squadron cause if you don't give her
that option you gonna be single player
like siren you're gonna get tossed in
the bushes by king david royalty and not
a pretender detrimental to an elemental
what's the avatar to a knee bender i
gotta be neato i know it's my destiny
work the cognito who
that's cool but i got bad news even if
you really was that jew king david still
be the king of the statues since the
juvenile i've been cursed with a curse
to be musical and if you hate it we'll
meet in the crucible other than nothing
it's cool and it's beautiful we let you
know that your dreams are pursuable
whatever you want to do then it's doable
if you got work on a sunday is suitable
cause you can listen to this in your
cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on a lord's day
[Music]
all right
here ye hear ye
and we are live
welcome to the iron laws podcast llc and
also live on lords of gaming.net episode
number 234 it's another glory sunday
we're back at the round table on the
lord's day i'm extremely excited about
our special guest and we've got the
state of the series x and s
massive back combat and fps boost
editions
20 years of xbox
halo infinite multiplayer and series s
sales to discuss so we're gonna get
right into it
i want to introduce a lord who in my
humble opinion is our modern day father
of xbox hardware
in regards to dual next generation
console design technical acumen for
developers and tremendous platform
feature innovation
introducing the director of project
management for team xbox and leader of
development for the xbox series x and s
consoles
the wizard of hardware and velocity
architecture
sage predictor forza horizon 5's
excellence with the most majestic beard
to ever grace the realm
live from redmond and kind enough to
make his return into the realm of the
lord
my man lord jason ronald of team xbox
how we doing sir
i'm doing great and after that kind of
introduction i think i should just drop
off because i don't think i can compete
with that
you allow what you do man an absolute
pleasure to have you back in the realm a
lot of things going on how you doing man
first
how are you doing what's going on with
you and uh what games are you playing
sir
yeah i mean everything's really good
right now i mean obviously right now is
a really exciting and busy time with the
20th anniversary as well as getting the
final releases out this year uh but no
it's a really exciting time to just kind
of reflect on all the great work that's
happened over the last year as well as
over the last 20 years
and then what i'm playing right now uh
i'm still uh playing forza horizon 5.
uh i'm going into halo infinite
multiplayer definitely getting destroyed
so if anybody wants
kd ratios hopefully that match with me
and then i'm still grinding on hades
nice
ladies even though i finished it
completely it's always that one more run
one more round
absolutely so addicting brother man
again we'll talk about the uh the forza
and uh obviously halo huge week for for
the team can't wait to get in but uh
we're gonna get right into it because we
got a lot to discuss but uh you know we
got those four horsemen of gaming those
original lords of the realm here at the
round table with
semi-time-sensitive intros because we
have a little bit more time with with
jason
but co-host with the co-host my brother
from another mother the difficult game
conqueror lord of his own world and the
how of the young wolf my man lord addict
how we doing sir
doing pretty good uh you know i
appreciate jason for coming on and i'm
gonna keep my intro short and i'm gonna
i'm gonna forfeit all of my power to
king
[Laughter]
[Music]
no doubt and of course we have our most
technical gaming lord the solo gamer who
lives for the single player selfish
experience and also the sastradamus
the lord of clarity and patreon of the
iron bank my man lord sovereign how we
doing sir i'm doing pretty good i'm i'm
under the table just like you so you
know i'm here
but i'm good i'm doing pretty good glad
to be here you know uh
yeah that's it i said no games yeah well
you know how it is for me you know how
it is like i i've been pecking away at a
metroid dread and uh i got two emmys
left those are the robots that are
chasing us i have two left so i think
i'm coming down to the wire a little bit
okay okay
what else i don't know how that game
found his way in the game of the year
but uh
i love metroid but yeah i mean it's
great but yeah yeah know
um
what else um so i played i i jumped back
into the dta trilogy quickly last night
they had a patch oh so certain things
run a little bit better
i don't know if you guys remember there
were like the raindrops oh yeah i
remember the raindrops like missiles
falling out of the sky
yes yes
that that that looks a little bit better
so they're working on it i'm glad you
know rockstar came out and kind of
apologized and said yes this is not it
let's uh let's work on this so i'm glad
for that
and
update era yeah yeah you know so
hopefully they get that fixed and uh
lastly i finally was able to download
halo infinite the
the bta and then
yeah
i went through the tutorial i didn't
have time to do anything else so i
played the tutorial got my little
achievements they got
familiarized with the mental boot camp
boy
much like jason i'm gonna get smoked
when i get it
so but just quickly on that like that
wow like yeah it's just such a polished
experience just from that like
knowing that this is a sort of
free-to-play game and they have to
onboard so many new people who haven't
played
everything is there for you like yes
even even the little bit of backstory
that tells you why spartans are cool
yeah yeah that was cool like it's just
for somebody just coming in you could
you can really become enamored with this
game not having ever played it in your
life so
what i've seen so far fantastic yeah
great great onboarding i have to give
you that for sure for new players and of
course we have the incredible hulk of
this aka the access gamer
the prophet of xbox swami
king of the statues who demands nothing
less than that premium experience it is
the leader of the fraud alert movement
be love it lord king how we doing sir
first of all i gotta blend the knee to
our extreme guest jason ronald because
um
when he said he was looking forward to a
game yeah and that game happened to be
forza horizon yeah
man you were on point i mean and and i
didn't know that certain aspects of that
game
like lived through my childhood like i
mean little infant king running around
his grandma house and it just yeah i was
listening to that song all weekend i i
purchased the song from amazon
um
it's sunshine if y'all uh want to know
what i'm talking about and uh it's uh
sound showers from dr buzzard if you
want to go get the original
uh uh album but uh
i mean
boy
i really i haven't been hit by a game
like that
in such a long time the visuals and
everything of the game is incredible but
let's get to my fraud alert real quick
oh oh oh well we'll get the fruit alert
already
on guarding them
man is that driving
what happened
i i sat there and i and i trucked
through that stinky card of a fight of
um uh
oh okay
okay
the what you call it the under cards was
absolute trash and they knew it was
because they knew blood was fighting
porter what i didn't understand and what
i didn't know is the politics of boxing
is really crazy guys and this is where
people can be disgruntled with boxing
and walk away from boxing in a hole
because this was supposed to be porter's
uh step-up fight and he's supposed to be
fighting somebody who's gonna push him
and i'm not gonna say sean wasn't there
to push him sean was there to push him
sean was going uh full force to push bud
and bud was there and they were fighting
it was a really good fight up until the
point that uh kenny porter decided to
throw in the tower on his son and his
son didn't even take uh hellacious shots
in that manner and it goes all the way
back to the fact that these dudes are
friends and their families are linked oh
no
when when is big money involved and
family and friends and stuff keep your
father out the corner um
i was i was really pissed off with how
it ended but he's gonna have to fight my
boy spence
you know god in them there will be a
reckoning for this dude because he was
exposed last night with a lot of stuff
but i love bud bud won the fight and she
salute to you champion but again that
ending was kind of fraudulent
um
where i'm playing but you're playing i'm
playing forza for the horizon guys like
you know game of the year for me um at
this point right now because i halo's
december 8th so yeah
um but cognito
what has made himself my rival
and he has some
car that he's driving in this rival
man i've i've logged in more time in
this game trying to beat this one
rivalry
and i don't know how he did it and
what's going on and i am infuriated to
the point that i have no
playing his ghost i am so upset and i
said yeah i could have gave him one of
my tracks that i'm real good at but i
want to be i'm no i'm going to beat you
[Laughter]
this little aspect of this game it's so
fun
it's the most it's the most needle if
you want to needle somebody yes and you
said you said the little challenge the
rival because who said it to me shout
out to uh mins from the clan he now
destiny player he sent me one and what
happens you end up playing the game and
you see that notification that you have
a rival channel and it throws you off
you don't you stop doing everything
because he's like no i can't have this
man have this time over me and you just
stay all day and try to be i'm sorry
buying cars i was in the auction house i
said i need a better car because this
man is crazy
probably a work or something but i'm
playing this game frustrated by virtual
cards
this has got to be the greatest i love
that feature what's up what's funny is
like there was this one match it was
neither kid smooth or diller
like just
mopped me and i was like you you can
have that like
i'm not i'm not running that back you
can have that that's the old yeah man
give a shout out to the delilah hd
salute every she just beat me in a long
distance race you know those races that
you go across the map oh yeah what is it
the the the goliath i think
yeah yeah there's a couple of them yeah
yeah
they're really long there's an
achievement for that there's achievement
tied to that
if you're wondering
i said if you don't stop walking fast
oh god
these cars is right behind me and the
last second i made a messed up
tournament
my heart's sinking i said i gotta do
this over but
shout out to the rewind feature
nothing would have helped me
that's why horizon is that game baby
that casual accessibility for a guy like
me
if not that would have helped you you
didn't hit that rewind button too fast
enough the only thing is when you're in
a convoy that rewinds
multiple times right yeah yeah but see
how you're trying to do it a certain
amount of time though yeah yeah it
should be enough
he just waited too long he can't get
some beta boy it's it's his ego got in
the way oh i'm in second i got this i
need that button
explain why you're a bear but what would
you play what were you playing sir
because on on november 15th
the greatest game in the world
king has returned
and
i love what microsoft is doing right now
the flair
for um
the dramatic yeah it's stuff that we've
always asked for them to do yes
and imagine if it didn't leak
oh
god
imagine that we're going to talk to
jason about that behind the scenes how
what what the what was it going on
inside the building too i want to get
that
there's some stuff there with that but
the fact some people didn't even know i
had people jump on my time like what the
hell are you doing why are you doing
this what's going on
so um and and i told him shout out to ty
guy travis and will me scream yeah i've
been playing with these guys all week
long
oh tat travis is a beast yeah he's doing
a wikipedia on the multiplayer yeah
so many little things
this is probably
the best halo multiplayer i've played so
far because it's
like uh and you see the bungie dna yes
what's the what's the name of the guy
that they brought over to
the multiplayer joseph stanton joseph
thank you sir yeah
thank you um
it's little things that i see that has
dna from bungie
opening up a door with your ai your
ghost basically and little hidden
secrets and gems
great stuff i'm getting smoked just like
jason
um but i got a chance to play with my
son so it's a generational game this
thank you i appreciate it yeah
and and the flare of dramatic is great
and
ending off the year in a great style so
um that's what i've been playing um not
too much of anything else a little bit
of destiny here oh outriders
new update they had a huge update
everything is a little bit different
they took away the times
what services
you see what's here no no no no no i
just was curious because normally i get
the plug so i was waiting i was like
what
know what it is is that a point right
now if you're not in game pass i don't
know what you're doing
i just gotta shake my head at you
because that is the greatest value in
the history of gaming uh shout out to
the christmas trees it's gonna be full
of game pass and you just gave your kid
over 200 something games and all that
back to past stuff yes the major games
new again no no no that's good salute
and of course we have the gaming ninja
himself the shinobi lord cognito
spreading that role into the roman iop
not telling what you want to hear but
what you need to here shout out to the
latest defining duke with my co-host the
amazing mr maddie plays had randolph
thor pull up man so that was fun yeah we
got to talk about everything that was
going on in the crazy week for xbox the
xbox 20th all that good stuff check that
out that'll be up later on last day of
media network for the free 99 also we
had an ultimate exclusive for patreon
users um talking more depth with back
compat you know and all the additions
and definitely i was celebrating a
certain uh g unit 50 cent game that i
will be talking more with uh lord jason
about as we continue so we had that last
word with ibontis and uh ty guy travis
that you mentioned was amazing we had my
man scarro nine up in there talking
about all the major sandbox changes and
the 30th anniversary of bungie coming up
so check that out that's up on iop also
will be remiss man if you guys really
don't go out and support the home team
lords of gaming.net with my man the
amazing editor nicholas downey we got to
play that halo infinite campaign preview
oh but thank you thank you man he has a
tremendous article up right now
logicgaming.net so if you want to get a
feel it's spoiler free so don't worry if
you just want to get a feel you don't
want to know any narrative beats just
want to know what 343 is doing on the
campaign side check that out it's
absolutely amazing and uh yeah as far as
games man same thing okay halo infinite
multiplayer been rocking and rolling man
it feels so good i i can't even words
can't explain like when halo's back it
hit different song it hit different
attic i was playing with attic this week
yeah bro it it really does like it we'll
get more into that as well on talking
about yeah get at it i i feel
like more comfortable playing a
first-person shooter than i have in a
couple years yeah yeah bro it it it
definitely hits different we get into
that and um
yeah so um guardians i started finally
going to start guardians i want to get
going on that all the 80s feel all the
80s kids stand up you know it's a lot of
love a lot of love going in but look um
soft you want to set the rules of
engagement because uh there's a lot of
chats you want to get a few now and then
we kind of gonna have to shut it
yeah yeah absolutely so ladies and gents
you know how this works when we have a
big guess we have to respect their time
and we want to make sure we get
as much time with jason as possible so
uh we're going to read the vast majority
of super chats after uh jason's segment
um
you know but they will all be read that
is for sure 100 so uh do you want me to
get something yeah let's get a let's get
a few let's get a few okay so we'll do
that give me a moment so we'll go from
the beginning i hope there was nothing
before i jumped i got that too before
you're good yeah i got it because i have
ksanti yeah that's good okay so ksi ten
dollars up to chat i see the lord with
the best beard in the businesses back in
the realm there's a lot of alliteration
there
please pass up class on our appreciation
for the hard work and ask if we'll see
some traction on the console game
capture anytime soon we will discuss if
we will questions from the beginning
we'll get to it we'll get to it
then we have lucious augustus five
dollars of a chat mad respect to the
lords and the ilp jason ronald made a
comeback all love gentlemen thank you no
doubt no doubt
and we have the dutch rudder five dollar
super chat shout out to the tech wizard
you and your team's hard work has
provided many including myself joy and
escape from the poo that is the real
world okay absolutely
then we have the dutch rudder once again
five dollars for chat shout out to game
pass i can now afford the game after
paying my child support oh wow
my god
focus on
priorities xbox is doing the lord's work
no that's real that's real real
clearly
we have black road inside out like we're
a member for seven months good morning
to jason the lords and the realm i
foresee a great show oh absolute eyes
salute
gerald mack five dollars will be chat
all hell the iop salute the lords
continue to make moves as big as the ps5
salute lord jason wow salute
uh cedric you shout out remember for 17
months
hello bro
then we have matt titch bomb five pound
super chat here we go on the lord's day
can't wait to hear from the xbox wizard
jason ronald ps halo infinite is the
goat can't wait for the campaign yeah
for sure for sure
uh then we have the dutch rudder once
again this is the dutch brothers wife
that he is still married to he thinks
he's so funny
okay wow
wifey got on the account
okay
then we have tony bryant five dollars
with jack welcome back to the realm lord
jason good morning lords and realm what
a great time to be a gamer salute
all right then we have big mad mo
welcome 17 months fantastic good morning
to the realm of the lords and the xbox
beard himself jason ronald welcome back
good sir yeah
uh a couple more and we're done
lane two super chat the c1 just shipped
and bud beat porter so it's a good
weekend okay
lg c1 salute yeah if you're playing that
up with a little man or what what are
you what are you doing oh we got that
little bit
there we got brian lane once again two
dollars for chat bud's a crazy finisher
porter was about to get it
don't don't don't have don't have to
cook your food
finish your food finish your food then
we have shane geist five dollars super
chat love the show brothers all that
needs to be said is the king is back
yes yes it is
then we have chani 10 super chat salute
to the lords on another fine sunday
jason and team are tech wizards great
accomplishments and back compat up res
and fps boost thanks to the team at xbox
phil dma spencer always making pro gamer
moves
a little felt dominance reference okay
okay then we have tyson lewis two dollar
super chat i'd be out here losing to
that damn ghost as well in reference
[Laughter]
listen man it's a physical sport
you know we got to forget the focus back
the lord jason uh the state of both
consoles you know um xbox back compat
fps programs 20 years of xbox um
one of the most iconic stealth drops of
gaming history this week and of course
you know that legendary halo infinite
multiplayer but first let's get to the
beginning with this um now that you're
back in the realm well jason i want to
kind of first start off with our state
of the series x series that we usually
kind of do and um first off happy
birthday to both of your beautiful
children your hardware children
they're one year old you know november
10th marks the first year anniversary
launch of the both consoles i saw your
passionate twitter thread it was really
cool you know kind of thanking everybody
the team so just give your thoughts
right now like you know what's the
feeling
one year in and how's the team feeling
one year of the series exit series
that's console launch
yeah that's a great question i mean to
be honest like i couldn't be more proud
of the team and all the work that the
teams put in for multiple years to get
us to this point you know and you know
shortly post launch uh you know i had a
message to the team which is launch is
not the beginning of the end it's the
end of the beginning you know and when
you really think about how much
innovation and how much uh change that
we're going to deliver over the coming
years but what's critically important is
that the foundation has to be
incredibly strong and i feel really good
about the foundation that we've
delivered with the sirius x and the
series s and that really is that launch
pad for innovation that you know some of
which we've already brought to market
this year
you know one of the things that i always
like to do is towards the end of the
year to kind of reflect back and think
about like everything that's happened
since launch and when i was kind of
doing that mental inventory just
thinking through all the enhancements
that we've already delivered this year
like i said i couldn't be more proud of
the team
you know when you think about things
like you know bringing dolby vision
support when you think about the 4k
shell
you know adding new features like
dynamic backgrounds oh yeah you know
bringing features back like the xbox
design lab so people can go off and
customize their controllers and not only
that but we also added new options that
we've never had before like metallic you
know bumpers and triggers and things
like that
um you know and even this most recent
update things like bringing dynamic
latency input back to the xbox one
controllers like those these some of
these things are things that we wanted
to deliver at launch or shortly post
launch but like the team just continues
to execute and continues to make the
gaming experience even better and that's
just what really makes me proud to be
part of this team
yeah i mean the iterations have been
absolutely amazing the transition right
into the the next portion what i want to
talk about is just that this huge
november update you guys just talked
about at launch you know what i really
appreciate is the the accessibility
features for our lords with any type of
color you know or vision issues and the
color filters that you guys have
you know basically to help with color
blindness and things like that but
a lot of dev accessibility features and
and and tags you mentioned the latency
the dli you know for controls even the
older controllers i could pull out by
you know my own
new adaptive control yes um
i what i've noticed what microsoft is
doing and i'm talking about across the
board for uh disabled gamers um they
have went above and beyond you can also
see that inside the games uh games with
um they have options of prosthetics for
the characters and it really hits home
with me because a friend of mine has uh
just uh recently uh lost the limb
and uh he hit me up and he was like yo
is is it true that you i can have a
prosthetic on my character even in halo
even in halo is so cool too
yeah no absolutely and for me personally
i wanted to shout you guys out um i know
it's a little thing but the all the
audio settings that were done because
i'm a big headset guy and one of my pet
peeves is what i put on the headset i
got to go fine and mute the thing and i
like oh they got a checkbox now we could
do that yeah kind of thing so again i
actually really appreciated that yeah oh
i love it i love it so get you know so
basically xbox continue to push you know
updates
feature sets accessibility why is this
focus this continued focus on this so
important to the team and then what
features specifically from the update
are you most excited for
well i think there's a couple things
there so first and foremost i mean we
say it but we absolutely believe it to
our core is when everybody plays we all
win you know we all love this industry
we love this art form most of us grew up
with this and you know it's a key part
of our lives and just because you know
you have different abilities than other
people shouldn't mean that you shouldn't
still have that same great experience
and i love how king calls out not only
is it things that we do at the platform
layer but it's also within the games
themselves you know because when you
think about a character customization
you want to be able to represent
yourself and you want to be able to
represent your authentic self um you
know you also look at things like uh
forza horizon adding asl uh to the game
you know and when i you know there's
plenty of people in the community that
we get feedback from and it's that
feedback that really drives our
priorities and it really drives what we
want to go to so you know you mentioned
the future of being able to mute the tv
when you have a headset oh thank god
like that all came from the community
and i mean obviously we have our own
ideas we have a lot of things that we're
trying to do but it's that constant
feedback from the community that really
helps influence the roadmap that we have
and it'll change our priorities and
we'll add things while we can and even
in areas where we're not able to quickly
respond to that feedback
we're absolutely working on things it's
just unfortunately some things are
harder than what some people believe it
is when we like that feedback really
drives us
speaking of features that people are
asking uh
and priority the the biggest ones we get
and i would be remiss i'm gonna mention
is improve dvr you know sharing the
social media clips um
you know another thing is i know you
guys are doing the dynamic backgrounds
now which is awesome i i think you guys
did a phenomenal job i think that's
something that you guys really should
take more advantage of especially tied
to games but um the other thing that
comes up besides dvr as well is uh kind
of like a pla
kind of a saudi platinum achievement
equivalent so that when you finish a
whole game there is some type of extra
credit or recognition of that so again i
know the docket's busy i know you guys
got a full bulletin board but are any of
those things on the list and if so um
any ones higher than others priority
[Laughter]
yeah i mean i will definitely say game
dvr is the one area the the capturing
chair experience that is an area that i
wish we were able to make more progress
this year than we were able to uh it is
definitely a priority for us we
definitely hear the feedback we have
made some changes and we have made some
improvements to the reliability and the
quality of the captures but we know we
still have work to do here so that is
definitely a priority for us and and
something that we're going to continue
to iterate on um you know the best thing
that i can recommend is if you're not
the insider range get in the insider
rings so that as we bring new
capabilities as we
bring new improvements like we want that
feedback to know where we're meeting the
bar where we're not meeting the bar uh
but definitely message heard and like i
said uh it's definitely an area that i
wish we were able to make more progress
this year than we did
but it will definitely be a priority for
2022.
on the achievements front we've
definitely heard that feedback as well
um you know and achievements are an
interesting one just from the standpoint
of everybody plays games differently so
we really think about you know how do we
reward people for playing the games the
way that you want to and the games that
you want to you know there's some
players who they just prefer to play
multiplayer and like what are we doing
to reward them or to show progression
and things like that there's other
people who like to play you know tons of
different games so how do we go ahead
and respect that that investment and
then there's other people like myself
where i'm a completionist where like
i'll go into the game and i literally
wanted to complete everything within
that game so it's a balance and it's
definitely an area that we've heard some
feedback on uh nothing to announce today
but uh definitely top of mind for us as
we look to the road ahead no doubt solve
addictive or are you cool with that are
we gonna be good
i i didn't like i got an avermedia
capture card so like uh i've never
really it utilized the dvr too too much
but besides like you know i'll take like
a picture if i'm like talking snap put
it on twitter yeah you know i i i i get
that like 4.0 kd on
on halo you know that gotta go
i do that capture
every day all day
yes yeah i feel i feel yeah well first
thing again would definitely appreciate
that it is being you know something that
is on the docket that is something you
guys are looking into and that that's
that's super important i want to get
move forward on
pleasantly surprised saw a pc community
update you know recently shout out to
the team uh lord jason beaumont i
believe megan spur
and um you know one thing that i know
i've been extremely vocal a little bit
tough on you guys is in reference to
you know the pc space and you know we
know that the improvements are made but
for pc gamers to really kind of
ingratiate themselves with the ecosystem
i feel like the pc game pass version
needs to be up to speed as well as the
xbox app so
you know especially now a lot of guys
are over on steam so my question is um
why should pc gamers be excited for this
latest update you know what are you guys
doing in that space to kind of bridge
the gap and make things improvements
there
yeah pc is a critical priority for us
and we've been putting a lot of
investment behind the scenes in this
area and you're just starting to see
some of the work that we've been working
on for months starting to become more
public but you know everything from you
know we've made significant improvements
to the xbox app on pc uh we've added
things like cloud gaming natively in the
xbox app on pc so if you don't have a
high-end pc or maybe you're traveling
with a laptop or whatnot we still want
to make sure that your games are just
available to you but then you also look
at games like uh age of empires four or
forts horizon five or even halo infinite
you know it's critically important for
these games to be able to be great on pc
and some like age of vampires four it's
a pc first franchise where when you
think of age of empires it's how do i
have a great best in class experience
and then even below the below the
surface with things like windows 11
we're making fundamental changes of the
operating system to make sure that it is
the best place to play game pass uh and
you mentioned you know there are some
updates that we're currently fighting on
pc today which basically you know really
opens up the ecosystem for things like
mods or giving you a lot more
flexibility in how you install games or
where you install games and whatnot and
it's really important to us that it's a
really authentically pc experience we
don't want to you know force a console
like experience on pc players we want to
be authentic to the pc audience and
we'll we have some features that are
going to be coming out shortly uh that
will really speak to that i would love
to be sitting inside those meetings
where you know you have the pc dudes
over there the console dudes over there
we want real pc experience and consoles
we have the console experience so i've
noticed that um when i do look at a game
pass on my pc it's a little less robust
than it is on a console but i also
noticed there's some games that's on
that pc that hasn't made it over and it
forces me to dive into the ecosystem
which is the same ecosystem but play on
kind of both sides of the fence because
you have a couple of pc games that i'm
dying to play on my big screen but i
have to play it over there so um
will we get and i know it's probably
licensees and things to do with that the
reason why those games aren't over there
and i don't know if you can like talk
about it but um on most of those games
going to migrate over we're going to see
the migration over from pc to console
and and console to pc in those games
that aren't readily available on each
side of the game pass because it seems
like it's a little divide in the middle
on certain things but will they ever
migrate back and forth over for the
games that aren't on each side yeah like
for example like a gays like asian
empires one of the things we do get a
lot is like you know wow this is amazing
you know rts and some of the console
guys you don't feel a little certain way
you know that they don't get it at the
exact same time so to king's point like
is it a situation
you know that from uh from you know
either configuration and they want to
take more time in the console space
we've seen that before with gears
tactics at one point where you know
whether an rts something will launch on
pc first and not come to the the xbox
console maybe come late it'll come but
it'll come later like what are your
thoughts on that
yeah it really depends on each
individual title so in some cases like
you said with rts as an example those
games are more traditionally thought of
as pc games and it's really important to
land them authentically on pc um but
then you know gears tactics is a great
example where it launched on pc and then
it came to console later you know part
of that is sometimes there's design work
that needs to happen when you think
about like input modalities and keyboard
and mouse versus controller you know
sometimes you kind of have to rework the
actual design of the game to make it
more accessible on controller
we do support keyboard and mouse on
console but it's also not necessarily
like a primary way that a lot of people
tend to use their console right so it's
like you know we want to make sure that
when a game releases on console it feels
very authentic and native to that
experience similarly when a game
launches on pc we want it to be
authentic there so sometimes it's just
the timing uh you know flight sim's
another good example where we launched
flight sim originally on pc then we
brought it to console and then you know
then when you think about bringing it to
cloud it's really about you know how do
we make sure whether it's streaming to a
pc a console or a mobile device it's
still that same great gaming experience
so it's all experience led um and yes
our goal is to provide the best catalog
of games wherever you choose to play and
if a game is available across multiple
devices things like cross progression
are super important so that you can you
know maybe start playing on a console
and then pick up and go on your pc and
then go back to your console because
it's really about celebrating you and
the franchises that you love
and just giving you more opportunities
to play yeah i i agree i think that um
definitely makes sense on on that level
also i did want to fall back on the
update in reference to development tools
because some things that we do see is
you know we want for example like a game
like the ascent or or something like
that it came out on pc you know we see
it sometimes there may be some
performance issues so it do you feel a
lot of that may be a result of uwp and
not getting over to windows 11 and some
of this will help alleviate some of the
issues some people maybe have with pc
game pass as well as you know other
tools that you might be trying to
provide to help improvements for
developers so that the pc experience is
kind of matching performance wise what
the console experience is getting
let's say for every update that we
released to gamers we probably released
the same number if not more updates to
developers you know and i think if you
look at any console generation or just
any you know period of time if you look
at the games at the beginning of
generation versus at the end of the
generation they're just night and day
different because developers have gotten
better with the tools we've gotten
feedback from developers on how we can
make the developer experience better for
them
also developers learn how to take
advantage of some of these next-gen
capabilities or you know maybe it's
it'll take them a year or two to get
their engine moved over and now all of a
sudden for you know the next three or
four iterations of the game they have a
solid foundation both at the platform
layer and at the game engine layer and
now it's really about pushing the
boundaries as far as they can go
so like for me as an example i probably
spend at least half of my time with game
developers from all around the world
whether it's our first party studios or
third party studios and just like we
were talking about kind of reflecting on
the the year of launch we've done
similar conversations with a lot of our
development partners of like hey what do
you how do you feel about the platform
where are areas that we can improve and
kind of push the boundaries and if you
look at the games this holiday you know
the games this holiday you look at a
game like forza horizon 5 or you know
you guys were talking about halo you
know part of that is they've had more
time with the hardware they've had more
time with the tools and we've had the
opportunity to respond to that feedback
to just make it the best place to
develop games and that ultimately leads
to better games for gamers all around
the world awesome awesome yeah love love
the improvement in this space the
continued you know dedication to
improving there and again i'm always
excited when i see those those uh pc
updates because my pc lords they always
hit me up get it at it and the biggest
thing that i really enjoy is just how
you order that it's like we want to
tailor the experience for a pc crowd to
the pc crowd and the console crowd to a
console crowd because i feel like a lot
of people feel like they need to be the
same and that's just not realistic like
they they're two different demographics
of gamers good point good point let's
move on and get right into this back
compat program fps boost you know you
guys made a huge splash this week
70 plus xbox 360 games i think um also
with auto hdr
uh resolution bombs fps boosts of 11 new
titles and then i believe 26 more titles
from the existing library fps booths
also rolled out on the cloud gaming
through their game pass ultimate and i
want to read the uh the xbox wire
statement from um program lead back
compatible program lead peggy lowe she
said while we continue to stay focused
on preserving and enhancing the art form
of games we have reached the limit of
our ability to bring new games to the
catalog from the past through the
licensing legal and technical
constraints thank you for being the part
big part of this journey with us so
first off law jason salute to the entire
team you know the amazing efforts on
game preservation the enhancements been
absolutely amazing you know i've been
seeing this program through the infamous
infancy days of 2015 a shout out i'll be
remiss if i don't shout out to the late
great late he's still live built so well
bill still was going shout out to bill's
still up
the great wall you know when i remember
talking to him about the program and
just being how amazed of not having the
physical hardware inside right and then
learning about virtualization and to now
you know i'm out out here playing my
beloved uh 50 cent blood in the sand
right now
you know shut up i went and got my disc
out yeah exactly i got i spoke it into
existence so defining duke with my boy
maddie plays and what's going on with
you though
like really jason let me tell you with
this guy right now i don't know what's
going on with what he's doing because
they're calling me the swami right now i
don't know
swabby bitty
he has to be the enforcer because he's
sliding his little note under
blood and these people that's why i
wanted to have you on let me slide you a
note because
let's get the real question what's 57
blood they said for me jason was it for
me
[Laughter]
it's it's it's okay man because you know
i hit up a couple months ago you know i
was like you know you need to put that
favorable anniversary 60 frames patch on
there too yeah
two for one two three
like that i'm hoping my my hopes and my
prayers for my my
beloved fable
[Music]
for real i mean
tremendous updates obviously again the
fable series backs pain dead space you
know i was playing elder scrolls
oblivion at 60 and it just it just hit
crazy it's different it is different so
i do i've ever missed i have to ask the
question that a lot of people are asking
this amazing this program is you know
many want to know but now back compat
you know kind of coming to an end for
new games being added right
will any existing back compact games
that haven't received fps boost and
resolution months will those still
continue to get
yeah
enhancements
mean there's a there's a couple things
they'll say here so first i mean the
team's been working on that release of
new back-and-forth titles for more than
a year now
it was a lot it was definitely a law
jason
and part of that was we knew the 20th
anniversary was gonna come and we
basically said like what is our ultimate
wish list of titles like if we you know
could wave a magic wand even though
people claim we're wizards we're not
really wizards we don't have magic wands
we literally started with a list of
hundreds of games that we're like okay
this is our fantasy list this is the the
list of titles and a lot of that really
came from the community you know there's
great members of the community that
would ping me on social media every day
or people who people would read every
day
oh he got the everyday guy okay
and then like people would collate lists
and they prioritize them for us and
whatnot so we started with a list of
hundreds of titles that we wanted to
bring to the program and you know to be
honest every title is a challenge you
know whether it's a technical issue
whether it's a licensing issue in some
cases the publishers and the developers
who made the game don't even exist
anymore so there's like a lot of slew
thing that we have to go do to even find
out who we need to get approvals and
rates from and whatnot right and
throughout the entire year that hundreds
of games really kind of winnowed down
into the list of games that we have here
so when we talk about you know we've
kind of reached the limit of our ability
to add new titles to the program trust
me if there's a game that you wanted
added to the program we've tried and in
some cases we've actually tried for
years to bring some of these games on
the program and i'll say some of the
titles that are actually in this batch
we've actually been working on for years
to get the right things and some of
these games i never thought we'd get the
right approvals or we'd be able to kind
of overcome some of these hurdles so us
this was really about a love letter to
the community and really kind of
respecting all the history that people
have um so that's why you know obviously
it's disappointing that we can't add
more titles to the program uh but at the
same time too i can honestly say the
team has gone above and beyond and they
were able to get titles that i never i
never thought we would be able to add to
the program good at it yeah
so i got a question for you jason
what is that biggest game that you
yourself like to personal oh you ain't
coming you coming like this was coming
to the program yourself wanted that over
it
you
you know it was it was a personal goal
for you for to get it to the backwoods
compatible list for you
so i can't call out any individual
titles but i will say i will say there
were certain titles uh that the team
worked extremely hard on for multiple
months
and they came through very late in the
game
because you know we knew it would be
disappointing if we couldn't get this
game or that game out um and you know
there's one or two that we tried really
really hard and ultimately they fell out
at the very end but there was definitely
some that were able to save and include
in this batch
but i can't really talk about specific
titles because like i said every title
is a unique challenge and they have a
unique set of things
and that's why it takes so much work to
bring some of these games forward yeah
yeah
one specific title that i for me i know
probably was hard to bring forward was
advent rising from from the 4g xbox one
day
again those guys don't exist anymore
right so to see that game the thing
about advent rising was that it was
supposed to be this humongous sci-fi
epic
three games like you know written by
orson scott
like
yeah exactly
to see advent rising there to be able to
play it
um it was it was something special
because i'm like i never in my life
thought i'd see this game again it's
over it's done
and to see that game and to put the game
on and the resolution is through the
roof right obviously it doesn't have
frame rate boost because it probably
would have broken a million different
things in that game
but
to see the resolution bump and see that
game and to still be able to kind of
you know
the the strive for epicness in that game
bro like the scope of this game just
looking at it now and this game is a 15
year old 16 year old game
um so like yo i don't know how much
money i spent this past this is the 15th
just going scrubbing through
specifically og xbox right because 360 i
love those games but they feel more
modern like there's certain ones i'm
gonna get absolutely but the og ones to
see them on there like i grabbed ditto
live three that was my launch game i
launched dave yeah yeah
yeah so
so jumping off to that jason right
obviously
back compat and it's for in this form
you guys have talked about hey it's it's
done we've kind of reached the extent of
what we're going to do um now thinking
about cloud and and and what cloud sort
of
enables you guys to do and then recently
also
phil had an interview with with axios
where he was talking about more about
hey
we need to get on board with this legal
emulation if we want to preserve our
industry right and phil doesn't say
things just to say them
so and i know you know obviously i said
back compat in this form is probably
mostly done
is there a future where we could
possibly see
emulation of these console environments
just in the cloud even if you can apply
like the frame rate boost or the the
resolution boost because it'll break the
game but the possibility to emulate
these platforms as they were
in the cloud and just allow
access to basically the entire library
of removing anything that has licensing
issues or whatever the case may be
is that a possibility in the future
yeah i mean what i'll say is like game
preservations and the dna of team xbox
you know and i think the cloud's an
interesting scenario that you bring up
because i was talking to somebody
earlier this week and trust me when
somebody was writing an xbox 360 game or
an og xbox game they were definitely not
thinking that 15 20 years in the future
this game's gonna be running in a data
center being streamed down to a mobile
device like
and like that's the important thing is
like we have this great library we have
this great kind of catalog of games from
our past and it's really about how do we
enable more people to play these games
you know you bring up advent rising you
know like one that i heard a ton of
feedback on was the toadie
you know togi one and two and like so
many people have these fond memories of
this and like did we know we're gonna be
able to bring that back no but you know
we went in and we figured it out and now
to have that actually available and then
i think the other thing too like cog
mentioned you know being able to enable
fps boost on these games running in the
cloud once again not only do we want
these games to be playable we want them
to be playable in more places and better
than ever before so like there's a lot
of opportunity here and you know i
definitely appreciate phil's kind of
clarion call for the industry because
you know back when these games were
written on the original xbox or on the
xbox 360 we didn't have this notion of
forward compatibility and like when we
think about like certain contracts or
licensing agreements or even like i've
had experiences in my past where like we
wanted to go rebuild a game from like 10
years ago we don't we don't even have
the tools to be able to build those
games anymore let alone you know enhance
them and remaster them and
i think as an industry we've definitely
learned a lot we've definitely heard a
lot from the community and a lot of the
things that the team has developed and
the processes that they've developed are
really informing how we build games
today with an eye towards how do these
games live 10 15 20 years in the future
so there's a lot of opportunity here and
the team's got some really exciting
things that they're working on uh but
like i said you know since we started
with this wish list of like every game
that we ideally would like to bring to
the program there's just some games that
unfortunately we haven't found a way to
be able to come uh overcome some of
these hurdles but we're trying to take
those learnings as we think about the
future you know we get you on that i
guess the because the the consensus i
heard the feeling i got from the
community was you know
obviously we love the work that's been
done
back compat so many games we understand
the challenges right we understand that
some things licensing saving something
from a technical standpoint but i guess
the second part people were nervous
about was fps boost because like yo we
like is fps boost done like is it no
more fps so like can you provide clarity
to the fps boost uh portion of the
program
yeah so right now we have more than 130
titles that we've been able to
successfully fps boost um and we're
always looking at new ways that we can
enhance titles whether it's resolution
increases frame rate improvements things
like auto hdr so i'll say right now with
the existing technique that we have with
fps boost we've tried plenty more than
130 titles okay and in some cases the
vast majority of the game works great
but then we find a game breaking bug
like 80 of the way through and like when
those come up a lot of times we sit
there and the team does everything they
can to try to figure out how do we get
over that but in some cases like you
know there was one game specifically
where there was a critical moment very
late in the game where an event would
not trigger because we're running it at
this higher
frame rate and at that point in time
like we're kind of blocked there so i
think with our existing technique uh you
know we've enhanced a whole series of
xbox one games with this release we
figured out how to fps boost from some
360 nog titles but you know we've we're
going to continue to look for new
opportunities and new ways that we can
enhance titles but we don't have
anything in the immediate future just
because once again we always treat these
titles as a black box so we try to push
the titles further than they can but
we're always looking for new ways to be
able at the platform layer to enhance
these games uh and in some cases it
works on a subset of titles in other
cases like auto hdr it works on the vast
majority of the portfolio so something
we're continuing to investigate it's
just uh you know right now i think we're
kind of finding where some of the
limitations of our current technique is
well maybe one day the greatest 900p
game of all time right son of rome you
know maybe
maybe one day
what i really respect is
you know
the put because you know there's been
other previous generations where
backwards compatible was like you know a
selling feature but i never felt like
until
last generation it was ever the center
if that makes sense and like i feel like
you know
because of the work that you know uh
that the team has been doing over there
at xbox that like you know you're
carrying the entire industry to that
standard now it's not just like an xbox
thing
and i and i really enjoy that because
now it's like i know if as long as i
stay with the xbox brand
i keep my stuff for the most part like
it's no like i just lose it and what i
like is
you guys go above and beyond now okay
you could have literally just kept it
the backwards we got it working that's
all
okay
we got to work but what can we do to
make it better yeah that's that's cool
and i feel like you know there's a lot
of scenarios where it could have just
went you know the latter where it could
have just been what but you guys took it
to yourselves like these are a work of
arts we can always make them run better
and i really appreciate that because you
know i can play as uh i could play fable
anniversary probably one of my favorite
games of all time
too
[Laughter]
we know why you like play with two kids
when
after that update like you can tell that
it's it it runs completely different my
my brother has been playing fallout new
vegas like religiously yeah that's
what's up so he he jumps on follow new
vegas after that update and he's like
oh man i wish i would have played this
months ago like i wish i would have
waited like like
i really appreciate that like just just
the i guess the caring that you guys
have for the industry and to make sure
that you know if you guys want to play
these older games because a lot of the
times when you play older games there is
a lot of like control hiccups that you
know outdated controls but at least like
stuff you can't handle a whole lot on
that but it's like we're gonna make it
run 60 frames a week and that's that's
the thing that's the thing you don't
think about right when when you play
these games like wait a minute like a
game like fallout new vegas or fallout
3.
they literally have to play the entire
game yeah
but i have a question for jason right
let's get it now
okay so i know it's financially uh
advantageous for this to happen right
because you released 70 games and those
dudes that didn't have it they looked at
the list because this is the first time
i've seen dudes pull up a list and throw
a list inside my dms like yo so what
game off the list i didn't even
i didn't even dive into the list because
i have the majority of the games anyway
so but anyway so
these guys is financially advantageous
for that part and then it must be really
gratifying to see that those people that
was distracters are now uh in tow now
with back compact because a lot of times
when y'all were talking about back and
forth people were saying oh nobody wants
this nobody needs this and it would seem
like every generation we would have to
sell off our old games to just go into a
new generation and build from scratch
whereas you guys put your ten toes down
and held firm
and made sure that this stuff came
across right
this list came out now they released
halo on the same
day as the list but what i've seen on my
timeline was utterly amazing you know
shout out to 50 cent blood and this oh
yeah
[Music]
of that nature were popping up was there
a game that you saw come across your
timeline whenever you did have any
relaxing time because everybody believes
that you guys have a bunch of time to
chill but
just sitting on twitter all day yeah
like he has time um
when you did get a moment to you know
take your head up and just you know
breathe it in
was there anything that y'all guys saw a
game that was on the list that popped up
on a it's a stream of just picked up
and was playing and you was just like it
felt really gratifying to see that game
even get the shine again
any game perhaps
to be honest it was honestly kind of
cool to be on social media within the
first 24 to 48 hours just because like
everybody has their own personal
favorites and you know whether it's dead
or alive or a toki you know and even
with that like a lot of people like
larry major nelson had the story of like
the first time he played uh i believe it
was fallout 4 like his game say from
2011 that he had like wow was each like
instantly available and it magically
kind of transported him back to that
time but i'll also say for me like one
of the things to your point of kind of
for me personally was to see the
celebration of the fps boost of the
sonic titles oh
that started different
to just see like as as somebody who grew
up in the 16-bit era like that is such
an iconic character and such an iconic
franchise and then to be just like the
celebration of it and to see like no
like they did an amazing job with what
they could do at the time with the
technology but if we have an opportunity
to shine it up a little bit make it a
little bit better like that was awesome
to just see that because you know it's
an ip and a franchise that so many
millions of people love and to be able
to bring that forward was just pretty
epic that was tremendous i mean
yeah i shout out to my boy on everboy
saga he was putting up clips and you
forget like in that era it that didn't
exist like song right like like that
it just it didn't and and another thing
is what let's say like
for like for me like the spoon of cell
games right to have them come back on
the console was special because like you
said like there might have been
quote-unquote better ways to play them
in that the pc versions were crisper
whatever the frame rate was better but
on pc
they never had it was they never had
proper console controls so it was all
weird you had to like reconfirm you had
to have those programs that reconfigured
like uh kind of generic controllers and
it never worked perfectly yep to get
those back on on the console like day
one when those came out that those came
out a long time ago now um to see them
running at you know 60 fps
it's just
the things like it is such a special
thing for everybody because again this
speaks to our history with xbox right
and when you can throw on a game on your
brand new console that you you know
you've been with this ecosystem 20 years
and the game that you bought day one 20
years ago is right there at your
fingertips yeah that's like i don't know
man like again it's empowering it's
empowering it feels like you get
emotional
i remembered it see because i know some
of the best right because
it speaks to your nostalgia because they
they
it it looks better than it did but it
matches with how you remember it yeah
because sometimes if you see anything
if you see it it's original state
without the resolution
it don't hit it differently
so when did y'all have that epiphany
right because i know it was the epiphany
yeah we're going to get these games back
we got the backing pad we're going to
get it running and y'all's like ew
are you implied at the 480i
was it hard it was it was like original
original combat of all yeah little
combat evolved when they brought out the
anniversary edition you can swap back
and forth right
again and the original right and the
thing is you even the original they had
it running in like a higher frame rate
so it wasn't exactly what it was but it
when you looked at the textures when you
looked at it back then it was
mind-blowing like i said i played that
game and i dropped the controller and
ran and i called cog and i called king
like yeah i need to play right now
whatever you're doing stop play right
now
um obviously it's not going to hit the
same today but that's what it is like
they managed to figure out what what was
it that you saw in your mind's eye that
can make you love that experience again
today somebody said this ain't it and
i'm gonna fix it
they got the team together because all
right so i know originally anybody that
was uh against backup
originally in their head was like no
that's not it dude man i'm not playing
there
they said dan's like no i believe in
this what we're gonna do is we're gonna
pretty it up we're gonna make them bend
the knee
to see the industry bending the knee
it's incredible because everybody else
now is like yeah you know our game's
gonna be back compact nice and cleaned
up but you were pioneered and you guys
had the freedom
you know slings and arrows of it and now
to walk in that room as as the knights
as the lords as as
the kings of these realms because now is
confidence when you purchase you know a
parent can go in a store
and know that the purchase that they
make today will stand the test of time
with that child throughout those years
right and
it's something comforting in that aspect
that every new console i don't have to
pony up 700
to to give him a new library him or her
a new library plus the console maybe you
migrate the console over but now with
cloud gaming my son
texts me last night
and i'm editing a video and he said did
you try cloud gaming yet yeah i
did that for a while but
yeah
he's like what do you think of a out of
the scale of one to ten
i said i give it an eight and he said i
give it a 10. it's amazing right now
because he's playing on little man
and now he feels that he's playing on a
series x
because the level of the performance
that he feels not saying like little man
is trust me little man is more than
capable but
it's that level like you you mentioned
if you're playing on a laptop you're
playing on your phone
that cloud gaming experience
give you that robust feel of a good like
stable pc or a high-end machine so
when you guys did this stuff there's a
confidence level going forward that
y'all instilled in the community and i
think that's going to carry over for
generations to come
and also uh
build a stronger fan base do you guys
feel that that uh the community is
getting stronger in in because there's a
lot of trepidation with some people on
this panel um
but
now the confidence is truly there that i
see because people buy with confidence
with you guys now with without worrying
about it do you see that happening do
you see because you get the dms and
stuff like that so
yeah i mean we're part of the community
just like everybody else so so we play
games with everybody you know even
earlier this week i was playing halo
infinite multiplayer with members of the
community we're always listening to
feedback and you know i'll be honest
like it we feel the energy and it's a
great thing for the team you know the
community is what motivates us you guys
are the ones who enable us to do the
thing that we go uh love to do but you
also hold us accountable when we don't
meet your expectations and you know the
constructive feedback you know we were
talking about game dvr and the capture
experience like we know we there's areas
that we need to do better and that
feedback as long as it's delivered in
the most constructive way possible like
we aspire to make this the best place to
play for gamers the plus best place for
game developers to bring their creative
visions to life and when it comes to
compatibility you know i think attic was
the one who was mentioning it before
like from day one of the design of the
xbox series xms we said compatibility is
going to be a pillar of this program so
we it actually influenced the design of
the hardware it influenced how we
thought about the business model how we
thought about how can we bring these
games forward and as we think about
future platforms or future opportunities
things like the cloud once again this is
now part of our dna whereas in the past
it might have been something that either
internally or we'd have to convince
people now it's like okay we have this
new opportunity you know we still have
millions of people that are playing on
360s today so you know if somebody's
still playing on an xbox 360 we want
them to have confidence that if they
move to an xbox series s or an xbox
series x that the community is there
your game saves your progression your
catalogs available for you so like it's
absolutely something that's critical to
us as we move forward but we definitely
feel the energy from the community uh
and it's a huge motivating factor for us
you know what i'm seeing and
at my job i'm the i'm the video game guy
right so everybody asks me the questions
and and what i'm noticing even a year
out from launch is that the people that
are asking me about oh what consoles
should i try to get for for my kids for
the holidays or whatever
the parents are under are now
understanding the language of
like game pass and the xbox e somebody
used ecosystem when they talk to me
where did you where did you get that
word from
and it was just like
it's this evolution about the message
around xbox and how it's affecting even
people who aren't gamers just trying to
like buy a console for their kid and and
the fact that you know
what is this game passing how many games
you get do you like do you get to keep
them you know all these questions that
they have but questions that last year
they never had just because they didn't
know what the hell it was they had no
idea and in a single year all of a
sudden the language around xbox is
completely different it really is a
testament to the work you guys have done
to sort of put that message out there
and just the fact that we as gamers are
also sort of proliferating the message
right anytime somebody asks me and
they're like yo playstation or xbox i'm
like what type of games you like right
this is what playstation provides is
what xbox provides and a lot of them
when you talk to a parent they'll say oh
wait how much do i get i said fifteen
dollars a month
that deal kick in and the deal kicks in
and i give them the tiers right and i
give them the two tiers of playstation
and and to be quite honest a lot of them
are like wow that xbox sounds kind of
crazy what do you mean this is going to
be in the service i'm like yeah you
don't pay anything additional it's in
the service and
from that they start researching and all
of a sudden they all of a sudden they're
in the xbox ecosystem and they don't
even realize so
the work that's been done there is kind
of amazing and and i you know you guys
can never count on the fact that that
type of word of mouth is going to move
the message that way but i think it has
it really it really really has in a very
special way yeah no absolutely it's been
tremendous to see and like you said the
mind the mindset i did want to double
back on we uh cloud game initiative you
know we know you talked about the fps
boost there but um you know one thing i
don't think you guys are getting enough
credit actually is when i see an
announcement like an ms microsoft flight
simulator and you say early 2022
but you hear about that coming to a base
xbox one
console right which was theoretically
not designed for you know the the the
the limitations of the hardware would
normally prevent that game for even
launching and running on the console so
you know to soft's point when we talked
about you know games preservation and
we're talking about you know not leaving
someone behind you know is the cloud
initiative this new way so that old
school xbox one s guys you know could
still experience these next generation
experiences when let's be real there's a
lot of chip shortages right now the
console sometimes is still hard to get
you know is this a way you guys continue
game preservation
yeah i mean that's part of it but you
know i think when we designed xcloud you
know to solve this point a lot of the
things that we've been working on for
the last four to six years are really
starting to come together in the last 12
to 18 months things like game pass
things like xcloud you know we've been
working on this stuff for a really long
time with a vision of like how does this
make the gaming experience better and so
like the fundamental belief behind
xcloud is this gives us an opportunity
to reach more players than we've ever
had before but as a as somebody who
leads the development of the platform
you know it's also an amazing tool in
our toolbox that now it's like okay how
do we leverage this to make your gaming
experience even better so when you think
about something like console streaming
coming to the console even on the series
x and the series s you know we know we
have this great catalog of games and
game pass how do we make it easy for you
to be able to try some of these games
before you make the decision to download
and being able to instantly jump into
that game and play it from your console
have a great experience and then when
you're done download the game and play
it natively like that that's really
about
eliminating friction for the player and
then like you said it brings up
opportunities for us with things like
the xbox one generation where a game
like the medium or flight sim as an
example those games cannot be done on
that actual hardware so now that we have
a cloud option and we can actually
stream that there for the people who
maybe
choose to not upgrade to the next
generation or people who want to that
are struggling to find a console you can
still be part of this ecosystem you can
still experience these great games and
it's just it's really about providing
more options to players so for me i
really think about it is i now have
another tool in my arsenal of things
that i can bring together and just
really focus on delivering the best
experience possible for players on
whatever device that you choose to play
on absolutely what what i really enjoy
about it is like
i see
you bringing the cloud streaming to to
the desktop that that gives you know
people that you know just have a laptop
something some type of option to play
games
i see when you guys put it on call so
it's like okay so you know
in the realm i can download something
or i could try a game out if it's if
it's uh xcloud you know compatible
before i download it so you know like it
gives more options and like and that's
pretty much like you know just more
vocalizing that you know the the center
of your guys is
the mission statement like we want to
give the players and the gamers more
accessibility and more options and i
feel like you know everything has
literally been around that nation that
mission statement yeah and and i think
it shows like i said i got community i
have i have another co-worker who he
came in and said look all right if i
can't find a series x or an s what i do
i really want to play halo i want to
play the campaign and the multiplayer
and i was like well you can there's you
can try to find an xbox one x or an xbox
one like whatever like it'll it'll run
on it it'll be there you can have game
pass there as well
and he went online and to show you so
the popularity of those consoles still
and the fact that it's hard to find the
newer consoles
like he was almost ready to pull the
trigger on an og xbox one launch type
xbox one
for nearly 300 like
this is how excited he was about the
prospect of being able to at least be
able to play game pass and get get his
halo on you know what i mean like
and it's it's just crazy the fact that
again that messaging is out there and
people like
i can't believe i can do all of this
first of all the fact that i can even
think about playing it on my phone or
something like that is crazy to me
and on top of that i can go back a
couple of generations let's say if i
skipped it i was on a ps4 didn't get an
xbox one and now i have access to all
this stuff and i can still play the new
things it's like you have to see the
wonderment on their faces when i tell
them this stuff they're like really i'm
like
the good thing about it too it's like
you know right now we're having you know
a new mass effect being made a new
dragon age being made like you know when
these comes out because people like my
brother you don't even know what those
games are he probably wouldn't play
those games anymore because he's a
weirdo but you know shout out to you
so it's just like let's say he did pick
it up i want to try dragon age i want to
try mass effect you know it's nice that
he could go back before the mass effect
legendary edition and you have access to
those games yeah and i feel like people
don't take that
people take that for granted it's like
you know
up until you know backers compatible was
you know done the way it was if you
wanted to play these older games you had
to go out there go on that ebay find
that console find that game like it
could it could it could cost it's very
it could end up being pretty cost
effective to to have to buy the older
consoles and have to buy that game and
then and then guess what now on xbox if
i want to play that game i just got to
go there search that game and buy it and
download it and that's all king you you
have a question yes yeah
me and you could play off each other
i was definitely looking out for you
brother thank you yes
this there's uh a great um
byproduct that comes from cloud naming
that people aren't really talking about
all right so when you go and you get the
external ssd that can come at a pretty
hefty cost
right and if you you don't have that uh
money right then but then you don't have
the space as well uh because you're
playing uh call of duty or you
downloaded gears and you had forza and
and it's and it's pretty robust in
taking up your storage space but through
the cloud gaming
and the streaming you can actually
stream and play those games without
eating up that uh console uh you know
space that you have there and i think
that's a huge plus especially for little
man holders uh that you know can't get a
uh uh um the hands on and when when we
say little man i i know you know jesus
you know seriously
affectionately call a little man in the
round
little man he be punching above his
weight
little man little man outside continue
you know the entry into the next gen
but uh
did you guys really was that a byproduct
that happened when you was worrying
about cloud gaming or did y'all uh
intend that to be
a solution for the storage uh um
problem
we definitely thought as an opportunity
you know because that's the thing is
like the next-gen storage you know these
drives are more expensive than a
traditional hard drive and we have very
exacting standards to make sure that we
can deliver a very uh consistent
experience both for players as well as
for developers um and and we've
definitely heard the feedback you know
people want more storage they want you
know larger capacities but with that it
also comes with the cost so to your
point you know there's some people who
maybe the they have you know three to
five games they're their primary games
that they play all the time and they
have them installed but we don't want
the friction of like oh i've gotta
uninstall that game to even go try this
game out here so with something like
cloud streaming i can jump into those
games maybe i can play the entire game
from the cloud or it might be wow i'm
really loving this experience this is
going to be one of my new primary games
so then you're at least informed before
you make the decision to uninstall
something or to move something off to an
external drive so yeah so once again the
the easiest way i can say it is i think
cloud gaming is an amazing tool in our
toolbox to make the experience better
for players all right i gotta i gotta
quickly ask because this is coming up in
the realm um
there's situations with the fps boost
you know i'm getting shout out to my
good friend horizon herbs here i've also
seen it from a lot of my you know dead
space one guys we're like oh man we see
you know the sequel and in part three
getting the fps boost but not pop part
one you know in my opinion you correct
me if i'm wrong um you know jason is in
reference to you know for example dead
space right
we know there's eventually going to be a
desk based remake remaster so it's a
situation that you know the publisher is
basically saying hey you know we already
have plans to do this rematch so we're
not necessarily going to give you
permission to enable this because we
kind of want them to buy this new thing
that we're going to put a coat of paint
on you know are those discussions that
are are had with publishers and the team
in reference to what can be allowed
providing that the title has no
technical issues and can be fps boost
enabled
not really i mean to be honest most
publishers like they love these
franchises and they they love these ips
just as much as anybody else so if we
have an opportunity to make the game
play better than ever before usually
it's a really easy conversation with the
publisher gotcha um you know i think the
the real hinge is you know are we
respecting that original vision of the
creator you know and that's why you know
i think it was who mentioned it of we go
through all the testing that we do
because we don't want to be in a
situation where 90 of the game looks
great and then also you get to a part in
like something's bugging out or like
something bad happens so as long as
we're respectful to the ip usually it's
a pretty easy conversation with the
publisher sounds good sounds good
definitely want to move on into uh
before you get into the 20th anniversary
there's a couple of smaller questions i
did want to ask um a lot of people are
asking about you know the next gen
features you know when when the console
was first announced you heard things
like velocity architecture direct ml you
know direct storage so
when do you think
these things are start to get really
utilized by by dabs on the feature set
i think you're starting to see some of
that today um you know usually depends
on the feature you know some features
require more work at the engine level to
really take advantage of some of these
also as you start thinking about games
moving more and more exclusive to next
generation hardware uh there's an
opportunity for developers to push even
further but like this is a regular
conversation that we have with
developers and sometimes you know the
titles are actually using these features
but it all happens kind of underneath
the scenes and you don't it's hard to
kind of equate oh this feature is
actually enabling maybe it's more
players than a multiplayer match or a
much larger open world or whatnot but
yeah i mean we're already seeing
developers take advantage of some of
these next-gen features um and i think
you're going to start seeing you know
definitely by second holiday and
definitely by third holiday more and
more titles are going to take be taking
more advantage of the full capabilities
of the platform gotcha so just to
clarify like pretty much the general
sense of what i got there is uh right
now you know because the transition
between last gen and this gen
uh they might not necessarily that be a
priority in some of them but the more
you see them drop the previous shin and
have exclusive next-gen games you'll see
more and more of those features being
utilized by uh everyone in the industry
that and also i think developers also
are learning what they can do with some
of these features so you can actually
you know plummet through your engine and
you have it available but now also the
game designers are really able to say oh
i don't have that same constraint
anymore or i can think differently about
this so you know and it's true of every
console generation often times it'll
take you know two to three years for
developers to really wrap their hands
around what's possible and i think the
other thing too is we we get the
feedback from developers of like hey we
have this idea we believe we can get
there we need we need to understand the
technology better and how can you help
us and sometimes that leads to us to
build new features uh on behalf of
developers to enable them to take full
advantage of the hardware so it's a
constant discussion between us and the
developers and like overall we're really
excited by how developers are starting
to use the hardware and you know we've
got some really exciting games both
internally as well as from our third
party partners coming over the next
couple years that i think will push even
further than the games that you're
seeing today
and then plus we've we've seen it you
know previous gens where you know the
the way games look and present
and you know perform at the beginning of
a generation it's clearly on a
completely different level with the end
because people know that hardware like
the back of the hand by then oh yeah let
me get in there again salute all my got
us a little lord acg in there much love
brother um shout out to that poll y'all
got y'all messy with my dravator um
what i did want to say you know again
you talk about later in the gen again
when we see this one of the other things
you know p a lot of games are excited
about was hearing phil talk about you
guys talk about waiting on the full
feature set for rd and a2 right
and then also things like super
resolution so is it one of those things
that as the generation goes on and it
matures we'll start to see
implementation of that will developers
mention this kind of stuff or you know
as far as utilization from the team and
stuff like that i'm just curious long
term with especially rda2 that was a big
what i feel
yeah i mean developers are using a whole
host of these features like variable
rate shading is becoming more and more
common in more titles and whatnot
whether or not somebody you know calls
out i'm using this feature that feature
at the end of the day it really comes
down to what is the quality of the
experience overall are they able to hit
their visual quality are they able to
hit their frame rate and performance
goals are they able to deliver on their
creative vision so for us it's less
about you know checking boxes on the
features you use those features those
features used it's more about like are
we really delivering that next gen
experience are really enabling that
creative vision
and it's a strong partnership with all
of our development partners and you know
like i said i mean i'm more confident
and i'm more excited for the portfolio
of games coming from xbox game studios
as well as our partners uh then i have
been in you know probably my entire time
at xbox because more and more the
technology is fading into the background
and it's really about the experiences
that developers can create so let me ask
a question um being that you know game
pass is really right now uh well cloud
gaming seems to be tied to game pass at
the moment uh would cloud uh gaming
uh be able to be ex um
brought in throughout like the whole
microsoft store for like games that
aren't inside game pass that uh you can
try before you buy uh as well um
in some aspect i i i know game trial
almost like i know where you're going
yeah like it's uh because a lot of
people aren't let's say they aren't in
game pass for whatever weird reason
how dare they king i mean
it's always a game pass shave but
someone doesn't have it it's it's not
game pad shame it's like i love a good
deal
everybody loves a good deal so if you
happen to have something that offers you
a good deal i don't know why you ain't
in it but okay whatever for whatever
reason this person doesn't have game
passes
okay continue
i mean i'm explaining myself for the
crowd you made it quick you know some
people a little bit slower just continue
continue anyway um will i game um will
cloud gaming
be available over the spectrum of
microsoft store
at some point
uh well what i can say is we have lots
of ideas of how you can use the cloud um
you know and you know one of the things
that's really important right now is
expanding the the access to the cloud to
more players around the world so you
know earlier this year we added four new
countries uh that have been supported we
get plenty of requests from other people
who want access to the cloud whether
that's as a primary experience for them
or something that's more additive to say
their pc experience or whatnot so i
think that there's nothing but huge
opportunity with the cloud
and we've got some exciting plans and
you'll start seeing some uh next year
and beyond okay pretty pretty awesome
last q and a question before we move on
to the 20th is this is actually my
little
pet
well the game update like for example
like you know you play it and then
you'll get that big old system update
sometimes it'll bump you into it'll kind
of
position you into say hey you need to go
into the offline status right there
there is there any way to kind of
circumvent that or as opposed to the
abrupt stop sometimes when you get that
update or is this something we have to
deal with i have to jump into offline
status so the uh apply the update when
we're ready
yeah i think there's two answers but so
one is we need to do some work on our
side to try to make sure that whatever
games you're going to play next are
always up to date um you know and so we
do do you know intelligent logic to try
to make sure that we're updating the the
latest games you play or the games that
you play most often uh but part of it
part of the challenge sometimes happens
is for example we may update the title
say at three or four in the morning but
if the game update got published at nine
in the morning and then you choose to
play at five o'clock at night clearly we
haven't had an opportunity to update
that so there are some things that we
can do on our side to make that easier i
think the other thing too is part of it
is is what actually changed in the game
itself so for example if it's a
multiplayer game or whatnot you know a
lot of times the developer wants you to
be on the latest version because they
might have fixed bugs there might be
competitive imbalance issues or things
like that so it's definitely something
that we partner very closely with
developers on but we also look at it
from a platform layer of how do we
eliminate that friction from your
experience
but we also always want to make sure
you're getting the best experience
possible which oftentimes means getting
the latest update right so it's a
balance and it's something that we we
hear the feedback on we've heard
feedback and requests to just keep
everything up to date um you know at
various times we've had that capability
but at the same time too that also
consumes a lot of bandwidth
and you know so trying to find that
balance and to be honest like what works
for say one player doesn't necessarily
work for another player right so one of
the challenges that we have is coming up
with creative solutions that really
meets the needs as of as many players as
possible while also being respectful no
absolutely absolutely i totally
understand that in the bandwidth aspect
very legit questions it's just me being
pet peeve because when you get sometimes
you get that big platform ui update
that's outside of the game and you get
the black screen in the middle of the
game you'll be like oh no
that's when you're in that preview
program yeah the preview that's true
that's true that's me that's you you're
talking from an aspect i'm being bougie
i gotta fight for me
you know you wanna partake inside the
preview program and i'll wait till my
food is finished
fair enough no don't bait a boy for king
don't beat
all right cool so let's move on back
because we got to get into this uh 20th
anniversary well jason you know xbox 20
20
years of xbox you know what does that
mean to you as a member of of the team
and microsoft and team xbox over 15
years yourself like what how does that
hit for you
i mean it was honestly the whole host of
emotions and just seeing kind of the
response from everybody on the 20th
anniversary everybody's sharing their
own personal memories you know whether
it's games they played in the past or
experiences like people talking about
lan parties and like carrying tvs and
consoles up and wearing things through
their house but even for me you know
like we showed like having robbie bach
on stage you know like that i
worked in you know the the team when
robbie was there or when they showed
some of the clips from the vault or from
the upcoming six part oh we're gonna
talk about it like
like i mean that is my life that is my
career and so like not only do i see it
as a gamer but i also see my career
history there as well
but at the end of the day i think the
the thing that was most important to me
was it was just a celebration it was a
celebration with the community it was a
celebration with the team
and as i mentioned before i mean we are
members of the community ourselves so
like we have our own versions of the
memories and just to see like how much
the hard work that we all put in and to
see how much that means of the community
but then also to be able to celebrate
together uh it was just it was very
heartwarming just seeing everybody's
recollections yeah i i definitely want
to shout you guys i thought it was well
done especially the power on
you know portion the the documentary
seeing like solve it and king would
probably appreciate that it was almost
like a
a renegade uh beautiful beautiful i mean
for for the lords it definitely
resonates you know a lot of us here are
from new york city we remember the
console launching it was on my damn
birthday so i had to find out what the
hell is going on with this system it
launches on my birthday it's crazy right
so you know
you talk about this almost like this
renegade team
fighting to get the impre you know the
attention of big microsoft well let's be
honest was it was really about office
and you know windows you know this game
got kick i see you ready you know no i'm
just yes first first i wanted to say we
have over 800 people yeah that like
y'all um you know jason is spitting
facts
and
please just share this out uh put them
likes in there you know show a little
bit of appreciation for this guy's a
world earned time yes because i think
this is the only leisure time that he's
going to get if you call it
it's still working we're still working
see you guys you know like running
around and
and it's
it felt like
first y'all was rebels right uh because
again it was buttoned down
right
you coming from the but it was like the
parents is up there doing whatever yo
y'all had ideas on what it was going to
be and we were all with you guys um i
learned about land cables i learned
about you know
ethernet stuff i learned about
connectivity i learned about all that
stuff
shout out to solver all right because
without why don't his technical uh
know-how
we would have been lost honestly and
then you know uh and in cog as well
so
to hear these guys everybody doing these
things and i and i know
when you guys were pitching it and and
talking about it and and and
brainstorming it
to see it spark in the manner that it
did for this documentary i cannot wait
to see
the six part documentary uh because i
lived that aspect of it and the fact
that bill gates name was attached to it
it was uh this uh enigma this uh
billion-dollar uh
guy this uh
our tony stark at the time
[Laughter]
but it was like to see that when i saw
that because you don't get a chance to
see those people in in public and when
you do and then he decides to take an
interest
in your medium at that time to see it
spark in the manner that it does and to
see where we are at this moment you know
we're talking and listen i i went to
purchase a console i didn't know that 20
years down the line i'd be sitting down
with one of the greatest minds to
engineer two of the the best consoles
that i have in in this generation right
now
and
did did you
even have an inkling
that it would be this
i mean you have your aha moment just sit
down moment to reflect because you say
you reflect year to year so i know you
take inventory so you take in inventory
over these over these years did you have
an inkling
that
it will reach this 20 years later
no not at all i mean
and this is the funny thing is like so
i've seen the documentary i helped kind
of like review it and provide feedback
and stuff like that and just to see some
of these clips from the past like you
know one of the first campuses that we
had at xbox where we were actually
building the the xbox we actually uh had
a separate campus away from the like
maine microsoft because we wanted to
create our own culture we wanted to kind
of you know really be very unique and
very in tune with gamers as kind of our
customer and stuff like that and then to
see some of these clips and to see like
there's a scene of jay allard's
skateboard boy yeah
[Music]
you know one of the first teams that i
joined uh in the company was actually
the space where halo 2 was originally
developed and like we had a kind of a
room for one-on-ones it was the audio
booth where all the voice acting was
recorded for halo 2. and like you kind
of felt it when you were in the room and
it was kind of like a special moment but
that now to be you know 10 15 years
later and to look back on it like it
just definitely makes you appreciate the
journey that we've been on it makes you
think about all the people that have
been a member of the team through all of
those years both the highs and the lows
but then also you know i also think
about like i was in times square for the
xbox one launch um and to be at the best
fight theater and to celebrate with the
fans and all that stuff like there's
just so many both personal as well as
professional moments that just watching
the documentary like it just
like it's like a yearbook it's just it
makes you think about all these great
moments from your past i remember the
xbox one launch as well because i
believe correct me from raw days you
guys had
rye son of rome centurions
that's why that game i think definitely
does resonate with me
because y'all went all out about like
one thing about microsoft when it comes
to a castle launched with marketing like
all the trimmings all the sauce was
there man yeah i got it oh top square
was a movie yeah i could just do you
remember uh do you remember the dead
rising zombies yes the zombies
[Applause]
you guys really know how to put together
an aesthetic yeah and oh for sure
that's where they get away i can just
see that like
like explaining that to like the the
people at microsoft that like you know
would approve the budget and stuff you
you need what
is that really necessary i mean i guess
if you feel like it is
just like a zombie walking around what
it was
yeah
and especially like you know i uh you
know not everyone games too so like
imagine if you had to explain like this
kind of event to a non-gamer like how
crazy it would sound to someone that
doesn't understand this realm
imagine the dude coming out his hotel
it's a little tipsy
it just comes outside to see zombies
dead
watching that presentation right
just like jason like you see part
obviously it's his career he sees you
know i was in that hallway i was there
and for me just watching those bits and
pieces i just remem i remember my entire
journey with xbox and for whatever
reason the beginning of my journey with
og xbox is very vivid to me in a way
that maybe other others like console
launchers or whatever aren't as much
and what i realized was that
for me xbox was really
the beginnings of my love affair with
with tech right
even before then like when i was younger
i cared about like mode 7 skating i
cared about blast processing i cared
about how that stuff worked but not in
the same way because i'm a kid i'm you
know my parents are giving me my stuff
although the genesis was the first
console that i bought for myself and
since then i bought them all myself but
it was still like something that i just
i didn't have access to of my own accord
xbox was the first console that i really
really had that it was like i i
purchased it with my own money i'm
living on my own i'm an adult i'm
investing in this yes and what i
realized is that when you look back at
the launch of xbox xbox
pushed me so far into the tech realm
because it's like that's the console
that made me buy a new tv yes right hd
era
that's the console that made you think
about oh hey uh we're moving away from
s-video we're using component video um
there's the first console that talked
about dolby digital 5.1
it made you go get a surrounding
facts off
all of that all of that facts
made you get ethernet because they had
the poor pride of that right it made it
they prioritized
yeah we were we were
but it was it was just such a special
thing to see that and like it's hard not
to get emotional because again it it
it's just been so integral to my journey
as a gamer
um to see
xbox be where it is now after after the
turbulence of last generation but to see
it come back yeah um and just to see the
confidence you guys have in the platform
now everything you guys do is with
confidence there's not a single thing
that comes out that feels like
even when you make a mistake right even
when you know whatever something comes
out and and the community's not 100
percent behind
yeah you guys boom jump right on it and
it's just like
and it's just to see that growth and to
see like you said like you said robbie
bach on the stage to see interviews with
seamus blackley oh the whole team yeah
and it's just
there's no way in hell you guys should
be where you are but you are because
again
there was belief in it i know cog at the
start of it was a little bit like i
don't know about this these are the
microsoft guys king and i were always in
front of the game we were in love we're
like
first yeah and
it was just one of those things like we
we felt it in our heart i don't know if
it was the sega associations i don't
know what it was but i'm like there's
something about this that is more
exciting than i've ever experienced ever
and i think solved to your point because
what relieved my skepticism because i
know you guys were first all the way in
and i knew it was a big thing but what
relieved my skepticism was starting to
see
the critical acclaim and it's a perfect
transition
of halo combat evolved yes and them
saying that this is a killer app on the
platform that's when we finally really
understood with that word killer app
yeah we heard it a lot we heard it from
mario
but it was the first time like to be
honest even if halo is just good
xbox isn't where it is today yeah sure
that's a good point yeah it's good it
had to be great it had to be you had to
transcend right well i mean you look
look at it from like the standpoint of
you know other
platformers and stuff trying to come in
the industry like they didn't have that
halo they didn't have that that game
that just puts you above the rest and
right
and i feel like you know especially you
know we're seeing a little bit with halo
infinite right now like people are so
excited to play halo infinite you know i
i've literally my friends this has been
halo infinite for since it came out
since it came out perfect transition
because i got to respect lord jason's
time here
you know let's get right to it you know
we talked about halo back then but we
got to talk about what y'all did this
week
you know this is a magic moment you know
and um you literally break the internet
halo infinite multiplayer launches right
after you know the xbox 20th anniversary
um
promotion
give me the energy in the building
because
my thing lord jason is
there has to be stress doing a stealth
launch now i know 343 has their stress
and you're not three foot three but
them working with the platform team
right and working with xbox live you're
doing this multi-platform it's not just
xbox it's all these different iterations
of xbox consoles and you're talking free
to play then you're talking steam right
then you talk about pc game like you've
got all these things to launch on one
time and to be honest i'm a veteran of
live service launches i always be like
yo the first day
it's gonna be rough you're saying like
log in two days later when the server is
settled like i gotta give azure and the
team came out really good really good
you know yeah there was that blue screen
for the first three two like five ten
minutes whatever
i feel like that was like a store thing
like right like there needed to be an
update on the back end to give you
permission to get in the game right
before that wasn't even like a server
issue yeah so for the first part like
you guys really pulled this off without
a hit so give me the energy in the
building stealth launch halo infinite
multiplayer what was going on behind the
scenes
and i want to add something on how does
it feel to wake up knowing that some
bomb info is being dropped and you just
waiting for the push the button
yeah i mean any major launch there's
always excitement there's fear there's
tension you know like to your point like
doing any kind of launch even a [ __ ]
like especially a shadow launch like
it's there's a tremendous amount of work
that and planning that goes into that
and even like when you talk about kind
of server capacity and stuff like that a
lot of that stuff is being worked on
months in in advance of launch but at
the end of the day you never know
exactly how that's going to go until the
title actually launches you know even
even if you think about even before halo
infinite with forza horizon 5 yeah and
the inspires that they were getting you
know in the first week of launch you
know we do all our planning we do all
our forecasting we do all kinds of
stress testing we have teams that are
absolutely monitoring kind of everything
that's going on to make sure it's as
successful as possible but until the
actual launch happens you don't know
with a hundred percent confidence like
how it's gonna go um you know and you
know
one of the really cool things is like
when you have a successful launch you've
done all your preparation you've done
all this work you do all this planning
of if this goes sideways if this goes
sideways and then like one of the
amazing things is is half an hour 45
minutes an hour into launch also you're
like hey this is going well like now we
can actually enjoy it right now we
really you know sit and like play with
the community and the fans um so no i
mean it takes months of prep preparation
to be able to have any major game launch
but you know obviously you know we with
something like this we want to keep it
quiet we want to make sure like we get
you know the biggest surprise that we
can out of it uh but huge photos of the
team at 343 huge kudos to our operations
team who are monitoring the servers and
monitoring the health of xbox live um
and it's just the team did an incredible
job to launch that this week and i'll
say for me personally like i've had some
amazing experiences this week playing at
night with you know people on the team
or members of the community so just huge
kudos all around absolutely
real quick just i mean do you how far in
advance did the team know they'd be able
to do this
it's actually technically it's not
it's technically video telling me
my my question is this right because i
was diametrically opposed to this right
and i was as well right yeah
i heard rumblings about this stuff um
i'm not an insider into that crap um but
i heard romans about this stuff and i
was like no
right because at this point in time you
know uh horizon is peaking it's at 8.5
going to nine and i really wanted to see
it's uh it's upward trajectory i i
honestly thought it would be rocket
boosters going all the way up right uh i
i wanted it to hit 15 honestly
right um
and um and i noticed it has a tick on
this but it doesn't have a tick on halo
and i believe that's because it's vader
right um
so when they were saying that it was
launched i i thought that it would
cannibalize each other but then i sat
down and i thought about it because we
had to debate on a show and then i have
to separate myself from my own emotion
of it right and i had to sit down and i
have to look at it um
optically right right optically once
once they attach the the word beta to it
again you have that little caveat in it
because you have business partners that
are strategically put in place for
marketing right so you can um
play under the banner of that that the
game is not officially released because
you still have your marketing partners
that you have obligations to for the
official release of said game right and
i said well maybe it can cross-pollinate
and bring those uh nine million eyes
that are actually active inside uh game
pass or in the ecosystem of microsoft
and pull those eyes over
to the halo beta multiplayer
and then i saw it from there and i said
hmm
maybe i'll be wrong by the end of this
week or maybe i'll be right and i do
have to bend the knee because at this
point in time the genius in the room who
said hey while this game is ascending
let's launch our next killer app and
let's see well later
let's see what it does in the wild
you guys are hitting on all cylinders
like from
2013 to
now
um you know it's it's it's a different
swagger like uh
sovereign was saying it's a different
level of confidence um basically it's
still the same marketing team so
you look at things that they've learned
that they've applied
um from leadership down from from the
bottom up and everything in between you
guys are hitting on all cylinders this
in this calendar year alone
you guys have started the year strong
and are ending in such a crescendo it's
such a year it is such
crazy you mentioned the medium right
and i want to touch on this this cloud
aspect is because the cloud is is is
focused in the middle
the medium could not be played on um oh
geez uh xbox uh series s right no no i
mean the one x the one that's the one
yeah right but not that serious one
start yeah look little me
little man got no problem
but
through cal gaming it can be
right so you enabled these people from
this from this beginning of this year
really you know really started hitting
your stride last year you know the
launch but this year you guys are on
such a roll to this end
with this halo multiplayer
how do you feel about that part is like
is it like vindication be honest with
for me it is because trust me it was
like eight years of uh
i have to hear some stuff but
right now it's like the trajectory is
crazy and i'm talking about the
projection for next year is nuts
with you guys how you guys feeling man
how do you feel like it's more about
feelings for you yeah i mean like i said
before i mean honestly it feels really
good to be part of the team and to see
the culmination of years worth of work
all coming together but at the same time
too like we're still just getting
started you know when i think about the
catalog and the portfolio games that we
have from xbox game studios over the
next couple of years you know it's one
of the most exciting portfolios that has
existed in my 15 years here when i think
about kind of the aspirations that we
have on the platform side and some ideas
that we have and some things that we
have in in the works you know it's it's
exciting so it's like you know you
definitely want to reflect you
definitely want to appreciate and enjoy
the state that we're in now but also
respecting the fact that we still have a
lot of hard work ahead of us you know
and that's the thing is not resting on
our laurels you know we always think
about like one of the things that i
spend a lot of my time on is thinking
about what do games look like in five
years or seven years or ten years
where's the hardware roadmaps going
where's the future of silicon
architectures what are the things that
we need to be putting in place today
because like we've said before you know
things like game pass and xcloud we
started those four five six years ago
well there's things that we're starting
now that will pay dividends five six ten
years ten years from now so it's like
you want to enjoy the moment you want to
celebrate you want to enjoy the momentum
that we have but we also have a lot of
work to do and and for me that's kind of
part of why i go through the reflection
process is to appreciate it but also to
really recognize here's the areas we
need to continue to grow here's areas we
need to continue to improve and some of
that stuff you won't see for many many
years
but you've got to have that long-term
vision and you know for as much credit
as you guys give us it's like you guys
are the ones in the entire community
that enable us to do what we love you
know so when you talk about that
momentum you know and stuff like that
like you guys have been with us through
the highs and the lows and you've seen
you know when
when it's been really great and when
we've struggled you continue to give us
the feedback and that's what really
drives us as we go forward as we look to
kind of building this best place to play
for everybody it's impressive man and
i'm so so glad you said that and
just the forward-thinking nature and i
think solve good get at it i was just
gonna say real quick like you know the
feedback the constructive feedback part
of the reason we feel so comfortable
doing it is because you guys take
constructive feedback so well yeah
you know
what transparency 100 especially you
know the marketing from the marketing
team to the hardware team to all the
developers like it feels like you know
that's definitely a huge center core uh
you know when we vocalize something you
know uh obviously
sometimes we be bugging you
but we a little extra sometimes
sometimes especially myself
i respect that what i like about it is
like you know so sometimes when
something happens you know someone from
the behind the scenes will hit me up be
like
this is how this works and this is why
you can't do this like
it and i i i appreciate that because you
know i always say this you can ask
cognitive king solve every time someone
tries to arm chair development
i'm like i'm like i don't know nothing
about that
it might send simple to me
zero knowledge in programming like
eighty percent of what jason's been
saying this whole thing like
your head is literally in the cloud
[Laughter]
all i've said is like because you guys
are so
easy to
give constructive criticism to and we
know that you know
there is a good relationship and good
feedback we feel comfortable doing that
and i have to appreciate the entire
microsoft in general salute to the team
we want to give you your roses on the
way out um like you said you know the
forward thinking the innovation i think
solve alluded to it it seems through the
generation of of consoles you know
you've always kind of been ahead of the
game and pushing technology forward in
the implementation into the console
space and now beyond like what king is
saying with it with cloud and and all
these things moving forward and it's
just been really cool to see i do want
to ask you because you mentioned xbox
game studios very excited to hear you
talk about that and talk about
development working you know with all
the teams and stuff like that you know
one of the one of your greatest moments
on ironworld's podcast was uh
it was highlighting you know game that
you were kind of excited for you know at
the time we were all excited about the
hardware and we were like what do you
know what are you excited for jason and
then your prediction comes out to be
exactly true the stunning masterpiece
that is playgrounds you know for alls of
horizon 5 that many feel should be a
game of the year nominee you know so i
got to pull an addict i got to say you
know
looking into 2022 it's going to be ilp
tradition yeah like looking into 22. is
there another game that's been announced
or not announced
i want to i wanted to point out
attic's not asking this addict's asking
addict's asking
is there another title that's been
announced or not announced uh coming to
2022 that you may have had seen and are
most excited for for the xbox like i'm
going to ignore this question
no i mean honestly like i said i think
the portfolio is incredibly strong and i
think the thing that's really compelling
is the creative diversity across our
studios i think there's something in
development for everybody you know
whether you're into shooters whether
you're into rpgs platformers you know
big aaa games smaller games like i just
like the creative diversity that we have
in our worldwide studios especially with
the introduction of all the studios that
we acquired the partnership with
bethesda um it's just there's just an
incredible wealth of some of the best
talent in the industry uh and it's just
exciting to partner with them and just
really enable them to bring their games
to life so i for me like there's plenty
of games that i'm excited about um
no matter what kind of games you play
there's a game coming for you okay
whether it's from over whether it's from
our studios or from the industry and i
think that's what's exciting for me as
somebody that's just been in the
industry this long is just the quality
and the diversity of the games that
we're all getting to play right now no
don't be like oh star phil got it
we're going to put it on jason
jason
now salute to him man that was that was
tremendous brother again beautiful
the lineage to history 20 years of xbox
you know just seeing you guys grow and
then you know to your baby your current
team this new generation of consoles the
dual launch and you know we didn't get
it blow via a little bit more about uh
little man but you know just to see how
well it's doing and to see in different
markets the s is actually outperforming
the x in certain markets which is super
impressive and just the feat of
engineering man i think that was the
vision though yeah be honest with you
yeah um i think what lot has to do with
the size of it a lot of different
smaller products
absolutely and the barrier entry is very
low so if you have any trepidation
you can always upgrade from that point
in but getting in and seeing it and then
you're seeing the ssd and you're seeing
stuff oh yeah and we got to keep in mind
a lot of people don't have
televisions that uh can uh take
advantage of certain things that's right
people are still yeah working officers
sometimes 4k is not even a priority for
some people right and you may little man
come in there 1080p 60 frames that nvme
and all that good stuff salute um final
question lord jason last time you were
here we always did the top five you did
your top five i just want to make sure
anything changed at that time now your
top five video games of all times were
final fantasy series including tactics
you had um assassin's creed as a series
you had the street fighter franchise you
had the zelda franchise and of course
the series that you're most synonymous
for here in the realm the forza series
so has anything changed anything moved
up the list anything needs to be added
removed or are we still maintaining that
five
i'll still maintain that five but what i
will say is there's a lot of people
really fighting against that like
they're all fighting to get into that
time who's coming up who's going to come
up
i mean to be honest like i still say
hades is an amazing experience i say
this is somebody who i historically
don't play roguelikes but just the art
style the gameplay the progression like
that's an incredible game you know even
something like i never played the
original psychonauts and to jump
nuts too and just really enjoy that
experience like that's awesome uh so
like that's the thing is you know i
think it was i forget who was on the on
the
podcast who said it it's an amazing time
to be a gamer now you know no matter
what kind of games you play no matter
whether you know you prefer japanese
games or western style games
like it's just like it's an
embarrassment of riches right now as a
gamer and that's an awesome place to be
in yes it is
we're eating at a fine buffet thank you
no no hamburger
no burgers
salute to the
legendary director of program manager of
team xbox a legendary
developer
for the xbox series x and s family of
consoles the wizard of tech modern day
father of x fox the legendary lord jason
ronaldo thank you so much brother for
taking your time hanging out in the
realms always a pleasure to do these
remember jason said he's not a wizard
[Laughter]
people expecting to like repair their
eyeballs and stuff
wise old gamer wants to know what kind
of cookies should he leave out on
christmas
i'm done
but look brother thank you for taking
the time amazing where can the five
people find you what else you got going
on on the way out
just honestly i just want to say thank
you to you guys everybody in the
community we just really appreciate the
support uh and just keep the feedback
coming absolutely you know like that is
you know that is the thing that is most
important to us we listen to it it
matters to us uh and we just want to
make a great platform for you guys so
just really appreciate everything that
you guys do and hope everybody's staying
safe and enjoys their holidays
absolutely brother happy holly enjoy
your holiday addict you want to get your
outros to him to lord jason
alex muted
still muted
he's talking to me oh he's talking about
song
you want to get yourself i'm sorry i'm
so sorry about that you're good yeah i
appreciate you coming on uh it was uh
you know it's it's always nice to have
jason ron with the mouse especially you
know because what i like is like when
you hear that
you feel like you know just
just someone that's passionate about the
industry loves talking about the games
that you know i've always said on here
you know i i value passion over
everything
so you know i definitely appreciate you
for coming on yeah you know and
hopefully you know
if any luck you know that that e3 will
open its doors the next year and we we
we can we could do something in person
absolutely absolutely lord some of our
trolls to the legendary lord jason yeah
always big thanks to jason for coming
through because i mean again uh
you say that you know it is due to us in
the community that xbox is where it is
but you guys you guys reciprocate that
100 like you you you've been supporting
us from the very beginning first time
you came on here ever since then like we
know that you watch our shows you listen
you know you you'll jokingly dm or
whatever and say hey man you said some
funny stuff there whatever and i it's
stuff that i didn't expect and i'm like
wow okay he's he really cares and pays
attention to what we have to say it's a
passionate thing and that's that's
really special for us because we come on
here you know
and when we talk about the stuff that we
love um and sometimes you know it's
great to have people come on the show in
the industry but to know that they
really do listen after you know that the
time they come on is a special thing and
you've always been that person so it's
it's nice to have
someone
ground us every now and then
no no exactly
yeah exactly yeah it's nice to have so
it's like yo i love the show but
because let's be real because sometimes
a lot of armchair development so why not
go
to the to the actual source why not go
to the devs why not go to the creators
who could give us insight sometimes when
we get frustrated because you know the
lord's going to be critical we're going
to say what we got to say but it's
always nice to get clarity as solving
and i think what that's also created for
for us and for the people that listen to
us is the fact that more and more
people that are in the gaming space fans
or whatever they really do have an
understanding of like hey
the people that making these consoles
are people making these games they're
real people they're real people they
take into account how hard it is for
them to do what they do and give us
these wonderful experiences so i think
that's just a
where i felt i've always felt there's
been a certain apathy that people have
like i just want what i want i don't
care how they get it done i think it's
like
yeah i i think interactions
real quick what's funny is like just
real quick like the whole
uh kenneth thing with the bush you say
you wouldn't have there's like five
developers that messaged me about ah
there you go i was like i was like okay
maybe maybe maybe i was bugging you look
look no much so much lord king let's
give jason and flowers all the way out i
just want to say thank you jason again
um i do appreciate you as as as a person
at microsoft but i also appreciate you
as a friend so i do appreciate you
showing up and giving us all this time
yeah
and being as engaging and and as as
thoughtful with everything that you're
saying uh and and
just giving a lot of people a little bit
more insight you know me personally
today was just really about the
reflection of how you felt during this
whole period of time
and the emotion i'm i'm more of a visual
uh connecting emotional type of person
so i wanted to know the emotions that
you were going through when you know
you're releasing your babies into the
wild and seeing the success that they
are having even during this chip
shortage and stuff like that and a
pandemic and everything but you guys are
succeeding in spaces where there was
doubt and i do appreciate all the hard
work and passion like attic said thank
you so much for taking the time out we
appreciate it always a pleasure brother
you enjoy your day and absolute pleasure
the legendary
chasing ronald put those little men in
the chat put those little men in the
chat no doubt have a good one brother
thank you again no doubt no doubt
let me roll back a little bit i don't
know if you have the pole ready to go
no there's no pole this week there's no
power there's no point
but i mean it's up to you we could take
it let me roll back already just vamp
first
yeah thank everybody i see the little
vids of the chat everybody pulled up try
to get it listen uh i'll say this uh if
we can get um
ten little men's shirts purchased today
i will play
uh community
game of your choice we'll we'll figure
it out for all the patreons and
subscribers we'll figure it out
and i'll play with it
and i feel like i feel like you guys
better pick something good you're making
me play all these other games
did you did you
know
no but he's gonna do it next week no
this week was crazy i'm doing it
tomorrow okay because i missed i was
like no next week next week next week
next week i'm gonna
[Laughter]
10 little mans before the show is over i
will play games
with those 10 people i guess or whatever
no doubt we'll figure it out let's
figure it out
salute let's start off with lord
roughness five power super chat shout
out to my four iron lord friends and big
shout out to jason ronald doing great
things on xbox cox drivetar upsetting
folks
this is no lie man i'm about to tackle
that dude later
also the um 10k shirts that's limited
just getting out of the stores january
15th all right no
get that go get that
did did my all natty shirts uh yeah they
laughed they live
they bought bashful no i said they ship
yeah of course they did okay
yeah i got to find out man because i saw
people posting my own that he's like
savage you know teespring does what tv
does
continue you got z black writer five
dollar super chat uh somebody sent me a
series x i had a lot of people thinking
that way though
oh
then we got burke andy five dollar super
chat just wanted to say y'all make my
day
[Music]
[Laughter]
we got the lord of technology my time
talk with jason i'm loving it oh yeah
thank you shout out to miles those are
the podcasts recently salute to the
brother
then we got doomy member for 12 months
oh yeah one year anniversary and jason
ronald thank you and team xbox for the
best next gen feature hash that quick
resume
yeah for sure
man hit me up man i get on that show on
saturdays but cameras on buddy yeah yeah
call it though
[Music]
[Laughter]
today
stand up
good morning lords and mr ronald jason
can we get a resolution boost on backing
pack game conan conan awesome game that
needs a remaster yeah you know i'm sure
they i'm sure they've looked at the vast
majority of all these libraries to see
what they could do so no doubt
we got splendiferous two dollars
jason you are truly loved by every xbox
owner that's probably true
then we have i'm an ancient gamer with
the 20 super chat
if he can answer what's the first xbox
series xs announced game that will use
vrs love the show guy so we weren't able
to ask that specifically but he says
within the next year or two we're going
to start seeing these these games kind
of come out whether they actually
you know highlight that they're using
that is another there's another story
yeah
all right then we got
to tell you yeah there you go
there we go
five dollars in the chat assuming this
is red before jason leaves
sorry sorry
will we ever see dolby vision for
blu-ray on xbox i expect that to be the
case
wait a minute it's not available yeah is
it joe tv yo
i don't know that's weird
[Laughter]
i don't i think it was already available
it was for games that it wasn't enough
that's what i thought i was like
inside the kitchen
maybe maybe you gotta check to see if
the bottom somebody swapped your sony
he's fighting for us
salute
cam xbox buy crystal d so we get a new
slash remake of legacy of kane uh you
know there was i i think there was an
article rumoring that there was one in
the works and it got canceled so who
knows but uh damn that sucks
and i store some stuff from it
yeah then we have rebelo
with the five dollar super chat this is
for jason well freesync premium or
premium pro works just like vrr for the
series x for example on flight sim you
can have more fps with vrr uh as he said
that stuff is still kind of being worked
on we'll start seeing more and more of
that it seemed like for the most part
this is
you know semi-new technology and yeah
even the people that make the game still
don't fully know you know they still
haven't really found out how they want
to use it yeah
then we got backstage for 10 super chat
loving my series x jason can we please
please get external usb dac support for
the series consoles i want to get the
best possible sound out of my headphones
i think that works i don't know if it's
like
officially sort of supported but i think
it works if you use an external deck
um then we have max delazio taco five
dollars from chat asked jason if they
ever considered bringing back avatar
awards for doing in-game actions or a
way to integrate xbox avatar into
windows pc
i'm sure that's all probably stuff that
yeah i think the avatars are being
phased out brothers no i think they're
going to hate them if if if the one
verse 100 come back they they stand yeah
probably not well you know the avatars
that they use in that commercial that
they have for like meta yeah
it could be that
yeah nfts
yeah they talk about nfts
no no the avatars themselves not the
nfts but the avatars
well yeah i mean yes can that be turned
into something that you can monetize yes
exactly
i feel dominance don't like the man ft's
what it is
what's up
someone said that you missed their super
chat i'll go back and find it if uh if
it was missed so just keep reading and
i'll look for it okay cool
uh
stitch with the five thousand chat can
you please ask him if the team is
working on any anti-cheat software to
prevent cheating in halo as we have seen
pc players already cheating three four
three questions that is
yeah that's not his question yeah i'm
sure they're working on it
um
[Laughter]
you can though you can't you can
try it yesterday you wouldn't let me
when i clicked cross play and i and i
brought the dropbox down there wasn't a
turn off available feature yeah for me i
got the um
for me i had the option to choose it but
and i was able to play um against
controller only people but maybe
something i don't know updates
that was like two or three days ago two
days loose out here boy continue so stop
sniping
we got the homies one more back slap
remember for 18 months shout out my
brother solution all right
halo infinite certified crack with just
a dash of fentanyl
wow
[Music]
trust me i this is one that i i would
skip over
the best fps to come out this year it
goes halo infinite it's greater than
split gate is greater than battlefield
2042 is greater than cod cod the bottom
of the barrel for slow mo this year wow
okay
then we got smit
five dollars super chat any game and
development taking advantage of full
feature set of xbox series especially
looking at uh machine learning and
velocity architecture no news so far as
you said everything is is fluid it's
happening
then we have chris mccomb two pound
super chat mouse freezing infinite on pc
anyone get this issue
get off that pc
again 343 stuff
my control is lit
i see
here we have then we have uh
your kids move five dollars
is fps boost
done nope he confirmed he confirmed he
confirmed that they any opportunities
they still see there will probably
hopefully be taken uh sleepy goblin 2d
can i get a t-shirt that says jason
ronald is our party's wizard
wow
no
you're a wizard jerry
then we have uh richard daluz with the
five dollar super chat when will we
begin to see xbox velocity architecture
implemented into games yeah everybody's
excited everybody yes he talked about
all that stuff they're looking into it
developers going to start utilizing a
lot of this stuff moving forward 2022
and beyond so velocity is the one that
um
the compression technique right so much
yeah i mean it's it has a lot more to it
it's like but that's kind of the
umbrella term for it yeah okay so
let's let's
let's be honest because okay i know this
this this huge debate right and you're
like oh my god you know because i'm
seeing it cracking you know compressed
stuff down
let me just say this right you can
compress down smaller forms of textures
instead of full 4k textures all right so
it's apples and oranges but if you have
both just play where you're comfortable
at uh stop looking for them compress
your stuff down if it's full size uh
stuff just buy the storage
pay that 300 pay the money kick david
yo please compress it a little bit
smaller so stop being cheap and just go
by the story
king david 21 y'all
body storage
king david just ruined any chance he
ever has of
being a
a marketing fan yeah
body storage
pretty sure i'm pretty sure
with all these games or something just
smack it out the way put the storage on
the counter
on that one
if we ever get like vouchers made for
any kind of merchandise on iop it's got
to be the all-nighter oh yeah it's got
to be of course of course you gotta
daddy gotta be on daddy
could you see someone like like clearing
off of like a table like the all-natty
coupon
[Laughter]
you're savage i can't black fridays
ridiculous
uh we have thx eleven thirty eight five
dollar super chat jason any news on rice
on the roam getting a pho oh i asked i
shot my shot i tried for y'all i tried i
tried it already exists on pc at 4k 60.
the licensee thing no actually no it
could be all the other things too he
mentioned you know remember you talk
about that
yeah multiple things it could be
yeah
mexican zoidberg remember for 11 more
shout out to you sir and then socrates
asked is it 50 cent or 50 cent
fitty fitty we call it the hood play the
game
yes sir 50 cent
then we have uh it's so lit mm-hmm
yo it is i'm gonna need the ball yeah
yeah
i guess
yeah he baked for 182.
it's not gonna leave my house especially
since people are selling it now oh it's
the hottest yeah
it was there for a long time and now
it's not everyone
but now
leave it to xbox to raise something like
a thousand percent on the used market
yeah bro
yesterday's price is not today's price
it's gone up oh yeah
oh bro
literally two days it was like 20
dollars
i caught somebody lacking like somebody
i was like oh you don't know
well he had to buy it now i was like oh
i got it
right now let me tell you
that list that back at list
i know they saw their numbers
that's what i'm saying part of me kick
is like yo you may need to not kill this
program yet cause you can literally get
some 50 eaten right now i think they
stay still looking i think they want to
refine it and and i think it'll come
back in in a larger form later like it's
a stealth drop later i think
the way it sounded to me is it was like
look like right now we've had our peak
but the moment we've because he he said
multiple times they're always finding
new ways of doing things it's like the
moment we can you know take because
the the passion that you know lord jason
speaks is like look like when they're
able to do it it's not a matter if if
they can't it wouldn't that's what it
would do it's going to get done yeah
agreed agree what else you got
uh we got
vaganell barboza with the 20
brazilian real oh oh yeah 20 dollars
let's go i have a question about
formerly xbox one enhancements that came
for xbox 360 games making them run in 4k
resolution any plans to add series s
support and to add that resolution
enhancement to more xbox 360 titles
thank you
not sure probably not but who knows what
else then we got the everborn saga with
the 2 super chat
shout out to jay ronald for sonic
generations fps boost yeah he was out
here he was happy everybody was happy
yeah he thought of clips he was running
all over the place but i love um and
extrapolate this
as you will but i love well you know
jason said that you know he loved you
know the sonic all right here we go
notice his extraness completely doubled
when jason left
it will be because i'm gonna give him
that respect
um
acg i saw that tweet
oh
so the statement from sega doesn't
matter
you know why it doesn't matter
no no no hold up before before you guys
keep attacking each other for the first
time ever i honestly thought you know i
looked at that time jason about to leave
like yo we bout to hear like two and a
half hours oh he's there you know now
it's over the thoughts of the early
let me say this uh-huh there's been
plenty of times i said i wasn't dating
that chick
we denied each other in public
but behind closed doors
until we decided to come out and say
yeah we official
hold up
no hold on
does it does your boo have shareholders
so my question is
you just make you just make it a habit
of lying to yourself
listen what you what you what you do in
public and what you're doing
already you already saw what bobby cody
did oh yeah that didn't work out well
time
time time
[Music]
[Laughter]
remember your knees are still on deck so
when the persona comes over
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
after he jumped out that plane the
legend dv cooper
five dollar super chat cox ai never
gives me a problem but that damn xbox p3
though i swear it's a conspiracy shout
out to phil philby outside running
people over yeah it feels outside mm-hmm
then we have ham solo
super chat
this generation is lit much love to all
i love iop thanks thank you brother
then we have kendrick starr five dollars
a chat what about connect with these
games he's fighting oh he's fighting he
fights
still works if you got it oh you gotta
have an old costume
yeah
still doing p90x
disable that they disable the i wish
they had it they're like another actual
game if you got the original you still
got your joint you can still play your
drivers you can't play no don't finish
dead
did you get did you get those from me
[Music]
lords kings gamers unite hello brother
thank you we're going to unite that sega
together too
let's go because you did another one of
those i see you
rub it in hey acd had to reiterate
another 50
[Music]
that's the knife for both of my knees
that he coming forward
he did it two times because he wants
both knees
salute
we got iron mike five dollar subject
football season once again here i am
once again sadly looking out of the
window and wondering if xbox snap will
ever return oh the xbox snap
remember that yeah xbox snap section
shout out to the resources was being
lost though yeah yeah yeah
that's why that's why that's my snap is
a wrap yeah that's how the snap is a
wrap
and snap that yes
continue there we go aj harris 5.00 chat
playing sonic generation on fps boost
auto hdr is amazing thank you jason and
xbox keep it up gaming is fun for all no
doubt no doubt that's right especially
if you got game pass
then we have
the everboy saga five dollar super chat
can we ask jay ronald if we will ever be
able to play purchase games that aren't
in-game king asked yeah x-cloud right no
i gotta give a shout-out to to ever
board because he's super chatted and
because his super chat wasn't read fast
enough he he text me yo
so i know that y'all was like this is a
weird random question from king
shout out though
then we got the wise old gamer member
for 16 months wow we all want to know
how did you get such an epic beard is it
due to mess shading directly
direct machine learning or velocity
architects
also what cookies should i keep out for
you on december 25th ridiculous
ridiculous
salute
ramtek five dollar super chat another
question for lord jason can amd fsr and
direct ml be used in cascade manner as
in will they work hand in hand no not
the other way around yo
you literally just went way over the
spectrum of my thoughts
[Laughter]
so can we use it in the cascading manner
because right now what i'm working on
brother
i think you really need to dm that man
then we got kyle new member let's put
the crescent oh put the crush on
then we got kendrick starr five dollars
super chat
will we ever get connect games and back
compact will i ever play dance central
three on my xbox series x people are
about this day about that dance that you
say you know who i would tell you to go
ask to don that yeah
he got a console for them
he's in the bushes
then we got clutch man or one ten
dollars of chat shout out to xbox for
their latest series s commercial a few
weeks ago i said they should get uh
copy copy to advertise the ease of xbox
and they actually did it kudos salute
i'm old because i don't know what the
hell that is what you need to do is ask
them to market and have me market it
stop asking for copy i don't even know
who copy is but you know me stop playing
no no
then we got style 617 five dollars
i've been a playstation owner since the
ps1 i just got my first xbox series s
and i love it i'm happy with boom got
that little oh man
thank you thank you you have evolved you
have reached the next level you got that
little man outside the last things
blessings you'll realize the dust that
will cover your playstation i'm done it
will be immense
then we have uh
gamonomics with the 40 rupee super chat
when will xcloud come to india we need
it yeah i mean i'm sure they're working
on all of them working on that he said
that he's worrying about territories
they worry about territories now
[Music]
continents exactly
mr kima five dollar super chat awesome
show enjoying the tech talk from jason
ronald hello thank you much love
knowledge
and we got drunken drunken ninja member
for 16 months
sir thank you
good day lords and lord jason ronald
shout out to xbox nation and shout out
to keiki who is holding it down in these
xbox streets salute the flute cake yeah
i don't know i don't know what cake is
what's going on so you hold it down
like she thick
ridiculous
20 years ago i got my first xbox and we
are still here
20 years in the game
i gotta scroll a little bit here
addict did you find the one that they
said was missing i don't think he went
offline for a second okay he'll get this
when he comes back uh we got mass erect
member for eight months shout out to you
sir i just want to say thank you lord
for the great content and guests you
have every week keep up the lord's work
no doubt no thank you much love
and we have black spartan gaming
super chat
happy belated birthday cogs stay strong
no doubt no much love thank you much
love
then we have lord metroid 2 super chat
king if metro dread wins game of the
year i want them knees
[Music]
um
and i'm gonna say this with all due
respect
attic butter
thank you thank you sir um i'm gonna say
this with all due respect
nintendo don't even believe that
[Laughter]
i love metroid and it's great game of
the year
tell your friends to buy the game it's
ridiculous anyway moving on no one's
buying they're buying you just very nice
yes they are you're being ridiculous
people no you're very ridiculous
from last year
[Music]
remember for 14 months good afternoon
everyone this whole past week with
everyone going after jeff has been
disturbing oh well that's just twitter
for you later guys
uh
i mean some people obviously always take
it above the line but i think there's
some real we'll talk about it but
there's
there's something i know
you know you know you know how you fix
it right you have the game awards this
year january in january right when every
game for that said year came out instead
of doing it when you're cutting it off
with yeah
and end of the year and you know
microsoft cadences they finish strong so
what you really doing and i don't care
about this you know there's a perceived
bias it's a real bias because if
playstation front loads their stuff you
understand that it's already front
loaded and if microsoft end ends the
year then you're already cutting out a
segment of the big titles so again there
is a bias there is a strategic bias to
it and i don't care what anybody say
when forza horizon is not in that list
and none of those games that in that
category can hold the candle to said
game i don't want to hear it and that
metroid jet throw that in the bushes
with the 480i man stop that
a lot of that's right
we'll talk about the details on that
forza thing because there's some details
yeah can you guys hear me yeah now
we hear you the zoo has been like
saying it's beautiful saying stop you i
don't know my camera's messing up zoom
is just lead the camera zoom zoom we
ain't got no problem with zoom except
you you know i i think i have i think i
have the 32-bit one down here yeah you
got you probably got the wrong version
and
i turn on my camera it turns right off
like yeah it could be older version you
might have to do it check update as well
continue all right next up we have
doovey two dollar super chat hit that
like button yes hit that like button we
still have 6 24 in here
then we have
spartan ghost 17 five pound super chat
best podcast in the community pegasus
nation in the bushes oh we're not doing
no name calling swami helping xbox bulk
up on that eldest girls meet pause all
natty all day oh my god oh
all the bad words
yes nobody calling no no no name
dropping yeah man it's it's it's all up
assets to ashes five dollars but my
assumption is that they will build cloud
versions of the og xbox and xbox 360s
like they have for current gen then no
back compat work would be needed yes
that's what i asked jason and maybe
that's in the future for xbox
um what is next flame five dollar super
chat quick question why does everyone
keep saying halo launched usually halo
launches with co-op and fords and i hear
that comes next year am i confused flame
flaming as he always does
don't play it
he died i don't think he died no no no
no no do like i did i have not played um
uh whatchamacallit game that everybody
was going crazy of which one uh yes you
know cyberpunk um until it launches
complete so standing at ten toes in the
ground and now he'd be about his square
i'm about that no no he's gonna see that
no he'd be about that i give him that i
see them throwing some tweets i'm saying
like yo
until the forge or whatever it didn't
come out yet god bless
[Laughter]
then we have the ever born saga five
dollars to be chat i was told the sega
deal is more like what they have for
fantasies that are online too
new genesis can sob remind me where that
game is available
are you playing that game
is anyone really playing that game oh
damn oh we shave it we don't talk about
it it's like fight club
fantasies
the sega messi this is still going on oh
i forget that game exists there you go
that's good a lot of those games that
you play i don't know continue
next big cloud game
salute to the homies happy birthday to
my brother-in-law cognito oh thank you
brother big cloud the homie salute bro
um addict did you ever find that one
that they said um it was the
uh let me look again
it was the black spartan gaming happy
birthday call stay strong black spartan
gaming um i looked right through the
super chats i didn't see another super
chat from you so if you super chatted
more than once
yeah definitely you know hit me up and
we will read that yeah absolutely but
you got that out of the park
remember no then that's probably what
he's talking about but even though i've
been reading everything that's in color
so it would have come up yeah
spartan goes 17 2 pounds super chat if
it was a kojima joint it would be on
that list tell the truth shame the devil
[Laughter]
it could launch it can launch december
31st tell the truth shame the devil
and we have flame two dollar super chat
i swear i'm done with that halo slander
now all right
thank you thank you sir are we all
caught up see
there will be no halo slandering there i
don't pay him no money see him next year
yeah last thing like nobody paid me no
mine and they all brought cyberpunk i
don't care what king say i'm fine
i will get the um merch stuff real quick
shout out to fuzzy belvedere you got
that dad cap salute no doubt mr joe
it's what it's called a dad cap
well you're like legitly called
it's legit girl dad cap
shout out to fuzzy getting that dad
careful you don't say he got his ilp dad
cap salute
and then uh mr joanna dark got that
classic t congrats on 10k can't wait to
wear this little man's shirt
got the little man's shirt up in the
realm no doubt then anonymous say your
name god he bought a classic crew neck
he got that field dominance maximus
aurelius sweater no doubt with the
silver salute to him and then we got
another anonymous he got the um classic
unity
t-shirt the sweatshirt excuse me in
white then my man phoenix down three one
eight what the classic pullover hoodie
little man shout out to the best box but
not really how many little mans is that
that's another oh man i don't even keep
up they've been by i mean i've been
seeing a lot yeah because i got to play
a game
what did you say how many did you say i
said 10. oh okay you talking about
shirts boy or emojis i don't know i
don't little mans okay
okay and honor jason ronaldo okay that's
about it no doubt no doubt shout out to
the best box but not really an xbox
podcast on the web i love having both
series accidents consoles it amazes me
how well little man keeps up and forza
horizon halo and death and hate yeah
halo especially i finally played on halo
little man with that so shout out to
phoenix down i believe we are caught up
there um yeah man so um real quick i'll
just read this last one and get out of
here which was um king's topic pretty
much um series s
little man again you know what i'm
saying and um shout out to games about
industry.biz data analyst ampere says
that xbox series s is outselling series
x across several key markets um they've
also seen figures that show series s and
x are at least 50 to 50 in terms of
install base uh in major territories as
a result of the success of series s
which is a digital only device xbox game
sales are heavily digital even compared
with ps5 according to gsd data over 90
percent of sales of call of duty
vanguard on xbox came as digital and
then um
it's been suggested by um ampere
analytics that the lesser powered s has
come into its own lord king this is your
topic as well as the uh game pass
ultimate perks i believe that uh youtube
premium drop yeah um
all right so i i never had uh first i
wanna tackle the youtube premium part
yeah because it's very small and it's
just an eye-opening thing i never had uh
youtube premium never
you know thought about uh getting it
didn't understand what it was needed for
until you know game pass actually has it
in their game pass ultimate there's a
perk in there right now so if you go to
the dashboard you're a member of uh a
game pass ultimate you can go in there
and you can activate that per trust me
when you actually see the backgrounds of
youtube ultimate you'll be really
so upset
that
this is just
your premium yeah
um
it feels like it's the ultimate package
for me pause
um
it is it's type crazy all the extras
that you do get behind it fidelity wise
uh sound wise uh uh instantaneous and
extra shows that you uh don't normally
get it is crazy um
combined with that crunchyroll stuff i
think uh game pass ultimate is really
becoming your media center to view
things and it's really good but getting
to uh little man
i kind of figured this would happen in
the sense that little man will be more
readily available because they were
changing all the server blades are
across the azure cloud with uh series x
uh
inside of them so a lot of those uh
shipments and allotments will go uh to
the server blades to fix that and
then little man will be available more
plus the point of entry is at a lower
cost
and the there is no shock to me that the
digital purchases rises on xbox because
again
if you're in the ecosystem is more
digitally inclined it's more for the
advanced gamer to be honest with you
because
when you get inside game pass if you
happen to have it
you can try these games out first more
and they're all digital and then you go
to purchase it's a point-and-click type
of system that there is they're getting
a ton of their money back because of the
point-and-click system and they have uh
bypassed the brick and mortar stores i
just wanted to know are are any of you
guys shot that little man is performing
in a manner that is
as far as even outperforming um the
series x and i did predict this is what
happened in the beginning of this
generation when they did launch it and
to see it happen so soon in this uh life
cycle is uh mind boggling to me yeah i
think
you know sooner or later
the series s is gonna sell the x two to
one wow i think once the hardcore
gobbles up that series x
and then when they you know once they
start really pushing out the titles for
game pass
people are gonna wanna go
and get
low entry to the to the ecosystem
for 300 and come out with all that all
those titles i think right now you're
starting to see some of the casual
audience because you've got to keep even
mind even though we're a year into this
generation it's still the hardcore
generation yeah the casuals really
haven't jumped over yet when the casuals
jump over that's where you're going to
see the s's fly off the shelves it'll be
interesting to see what's going on lord
sav your thoughts series s and then
these are gay past ultimate perks
yeah i mean we talked about it as soon
as we knew what the s was we're like
yeah this is it this is going to be the
one that that again like attic pointed
to one like king pointed to
this is the machine that's going to it's
going to draw in the casual this is the
one that you know especially now when
you think about
its availability in regard in comparison
to the x people are just going to
get anything they can get their hands on
to jump into this ecosystem because now
the message of game pass is out there
and people like wait a minute like all
of a sudden now the promise of game pass
and having these top tier aaa games in
there in addition to smaller stuff in
addition to third-party stuff it's all
finally coming together and i tell you
right now you know if if the world were
in a different place in a different
situation
i i think that tutor won't be happening
right now like honestly
because it it's it's really it's second
year on the market right it is kind of
like its secondary launch because of
because of how limited launch was last
year right um you finally have these
games coming to game pass you have the
flagship and halo you have the other
flagship and forza right um there's no
better time right yeah so to me this was
this was always coming but
the fact that what they did with this
machine is like
it's not a [ __ ] machine per se
what they're telling you is this is a
machine for this type of setup but in
terms of the the next gen features that
you can expect on the x for the most
part except resolution it's all there
yeah it's all there and that that's a
very telling thing even to the hardcore
right obviously the price point the
price point is going to going to speak
to the casual
but to the hardcore
that wants a secondary console
or who's been on the other side of the
fence and wants to now test the waters
on xbox this is still the perfect choice
bg
bg word to the perfect way
500
is is too high but 300 is it composed by
yeah
you go to walmart you see that you like
it is that type of thing like for this
type of tech right 300 is an impulse buy
300 is i see it on the line when i'm
waiting to pay for something and i say
why not right like you throw the bundles
you throw the deals the holiday deals
you throw you know exactly you know six
months a game pass a year game pass it's
like what you said with your friend he's
trying to find a series as the series x
anything
and
imagine
when the next gears pops out when halo
actually officially launches and and
then you and then they start because i
don't think we're going to see it now
because of the pandemic has shortened a
lot of stuff so they're really they're
they're more worried about getting pla
consoles not necessarily about like
reads uh like having like a specialized
console so like imagine when you know
hey like the next gear is fable like
hellblade and when you go there on the
box it says hellblade right and then
there you go
first party start hitting hellblade's
probably not gonna be with the console
but they're probably gonna put that one
to three months game pass in that
console and you'll be able to play that
game through that search but i wouldn't
i wouldn't yeah guys i got finished i
forgot just to go no that's fine
and i'll jump back in go ahead no no i
was just visualizing as you go later in
the gym kind of what attic is saying
like when you go later in the gym i'm so
used to
you know when that joint maybe four or
five years don't even hit a little 250 a
little three
and then it's like oh now you're
bundling you know with the um like a
game that is xbox first party game
studio when those games when those games
really start hitting and then you got
those people who
were let's say for example playstation 4
owners right who abstain from an xbox
that generation and then you go and get
that impulse bob because you see this
amazing day like damn these are them
titles and i could just pay this right
now and walk out you know what i'm
saying with this joint so it is
interesting i'm curious though if they
um because of the speaker on it
if like because you know the series x is
more
custom console
friendly
so i'm curious to see if little man is
going to get custom because he got that
big he got that big speaker so oh no
that speaker allowed him to get busy
with the customer
i think that somebody will figure it out
i think
i think they're probably not going to
stick to custom like ex like halo
consoles i think they're going to
probably maybe they might do that once
or twice but very curious you're gonna
see different color xbox yeah yeah
probably different color yeah yeah i
think you're gonna see more of that
maybe when the next four as it comes out
you see a purple for uh
i think that's only and you're on or
something i think that's only when the
console achieves a certain level of
status right because we see that with
nintendo
every time nintendo hits a certain
milestone of console sales and this is
mainly with their handhelds they would
do a see-through they would do a blue
they would do a different color so i
think you're onto something that it it
actually has to hit them we have to
remember we have to make to king's point
like we could see we can see a
straight-up redesign of it right it
could be even smaller in the region you
know what i kind of would have liked i
know
there was a lot of
like
fake artwork that came out there for the
xbox series s before it came out there
was one that was the x but smaller
looked like a little like looked like a
game
i was like i remember that i really
wanted that to be true like like and i
know like it looked like a smaller like
probably around the same size as the
gamecube because i was like i don't know
why but i've always liked the design
aesthetics of that gamecube they've got
a little handle they have a little
handle yeah
i mean they're joining us
and you know that that's why i feel like
you're gonna start seeing them i don't
think they're going to really do the
color thing too much they might do it
every now and then like oh we got a blue
skill or forza comes out we we got a
orange skill or something like that but
yeah i think you're going to see them
really focusing on what the console
box looks like they're gonna have like a
hellblade two one that's on the cover oh
i see what you say like
i like that i think they're going to
really
market
the s and the uh
mainly the ass i think the x is going to
do it too but that's really yeah off the
games that's going to be coming off
because i remember with the 1s you got
the box packaging and then you do a
packing digital pack in right with a
game let's say one of them hot games
really start hitting you know like i
don't know star field or whatever
whatever you can you can start building
them packing boxes and a digital code
and you're like yo right now you s
starfield exclusive the series you know
what i mean like that all of these games
that have just come out all of a sudden
you have a three-month access yeah and
it's like yeah you got the you got the
game
and imagine when
this year
regardless what people feel and
regardless how some of these games have
not been exclusive
microsoft studios have had a fantastic
year oh yeah this year has been
tremendous
crazy imagine you continue this because
i don't think next year is going to be
any different you have star feel coming
out you have red fall coming out uh
you're going to have the motorsports
coming out like obviously you're going
to have those little indies they
sprinkle through there e3 they love to
announce something that comes out like a
couple months after that like a smaller
title and you probably have a couple of
big third parties third party games yeah
an exclusive game pass exclusive day of
date possibly that that's what i'm
looking at like
people are going to constantly see
game pass in the news constantly oh this
game's coming out red falls coming out
starfield's coming up and imagine a star
field hits
it that'll be different i think it's
going to hit you know what's kind of
crazy what
as much as i'm playing as forza right
now right you know it's open world it's
crazy the world is open
when they shrink that world down that
it's just track base
and they do that forza motors that's all
you right there you lie that i mean
i'm just thinking about the level of
fidelity oh yeah they're going to push
it yeah because he's going to be next
gen he's not going to because it's
amazing you're right it's amazing as
horizon look it's across jen gay right
you know what i thought would be funny
people
okay let's say fable comes out all right
fable comes out and then
fours or horizon six or whatever that
one would be called because i because
sometimes they stop numbering them and
they start naming them something like
forza horizon britain or something like
they have an expansion for it that's
like you driving in the in albion and
the famed dabbing
so but yeah i mean i guess i'll let you
finish that i'll finish
yeah because i want to speak a little
bit to the crunchyroll and the uh the
youtube premium
that is very interesting he just sat
close to the mic
why is that interesting song
even though they're just free trials
right you still have to pay for them
separately or not
the fact that these kinds of plays are
happening if you think about
how we talked about playstation in
particular playstation now right and how
they were seeking to grow that as as as
a platform right and they had this uh
the these sort of test beds for uh
playstation movies or whatever i forgot
what it's called they just like their
their their movie sort of platform
specifically for the playstation they're
testing it in other countries and
whatnot
that to me in a lot of ways presents an
easy way for the casual to get in
because even if they're not big time
gamers when you give them a package that
includes all of these television and and
movie options and entertainment options
in addition to the gaming stuff right
now all of a sudden you start creating a
reason for them to come to this platform
for other things than games right right
and i think
the combination of game pass ultimate
little man in the price point
the point of entry and then you start
you start positioning game pass as also
this
widespread entertainment thing yeah and
not just gaming tv
watch out
watch out
but it's not it's not tv tv tv right
it's not that it's not that but the fact
that i'm okay with with the tv being the
side piece all right
because again all you have access to all
these stuff as individual apps on xbox
anyway if you wanted it right right xbox
could be the platform for you to use
this
the fact that they're enveloping it and
rolling it into games
he's laughing like i was saying that
like uh crunchyroll funimation is like
low-key that side piece and if you're
looking from an aesthetic wise i guess
sony is microsoft's side piece right now
no it's like yes it's just the bull on
the side like
not close
i want you to look at it right
[Music]
this is really funny right i really want
you to look at it yes
sometimes it's the packaging that turns
you off right right and how somebody
delivers a message
change the packaging
and speak a little bit softer
so this is the way to finesse the tv
back
[Laughter]
yeah they were talking they were talking
tv not a seduction
stuff right and right now
crunchyroll youtubers slid through it's
tv and they slid it in pause
everybody's falling for it
listen man
it's that but we know this right you
know
that listen the don didn't know how to
he you trying to say the dog they have a
game with his tv tv
i tried
[Music]
we messing around and not all right
he bad director no drinks
there was no dinner nothing nothing it
was just [ __ ] go home or not we go
you go with the tv or not i'm
of
done
oh dude listen this this new gen they
definitely
they definitely know how to finesse they
definitely gotta finesse stuff in man
oh what do you what do you mean go home
and watch tv
oh you're trying to crunch your own
chill
anyway
a little bit of premium youtube
i do find it i'm with attic though as
far as the old the console thing i think
right now once the chip shortages get
better you'll see the series x jump out
but
i do think that in key markets the s
will be
ahead
always in certain key markets especially
yeah
and the digital thing yeah the digital
thing is big for them um look they're in
position that i'm very impressed with
the series i've been using it a lot now
like i said i traveled when i went to
the lsm event you know with the guys it
was amazing i just played halo infinite
on it i didn't feel i was missing the
beat and i was doing 120 or yeah i'm
doing 120 hertz halo i've been playing
um forza horizon 5 and the b you know
how it is when you get us
back in there you get the smaller the
lesser console and you feel like oh yeah
i can see i'm not really see i'm like yo
little
little man is out here like he's it's
really impressive i'm very impressed
with that system and just how small it
is you can just move it around so yeah
they got one they got one they really
did a good job i think it's only a
matter of time as the gen goes on and
don't let like let's say we mid gen
next gen don't let the two hundred
dollars go there oh yeah oh no
that's definitely happening but you know
what's crazy like i don't know nothing
about like you know
making products like that yeah that s is
so small one would think it like if down
the road where it became so if they
could make it even smaller that's crazy
no it's like put it smaller like
it's so small i'm sitting here thinking
once that they start incorporating that
in tvs like where like it's built into
the tv because instead of just the app
just incorporating the articles
we got to see it it's that small like
imagine like but i think i think the dvd
player and tv thing like i think they'd
rather use push cloud right
yeah but in certain regions that's not
possible right right right right but
it's still a digital but you still it
still don't make no sense because
remember the s is still a digital only
you need to be
right you know
yeah you still need to dig
the most sense then because they
wouldn't they wouldn't need anything to
to incorporate outside he could
literally strictly inside the tv yeah
the only thing is you you have to have
like
three downloads and that's it tops and
that's three downloads
but look that's what i got man but yeah
to the other service i agree i think
kick is right you know they are
definitely have all these ridiculous
perks with this game pass ultimate and
they they're amazing deals like i did
not see this coming so i think they're
going to do lots more this stuff moving
forward and don't let them put that
disney plus in there as well too that's
another one so we'll see as they keep
making it
yeah well
just a three-month thing yeah but it's
just a way to get you in you know what i
mean so oh yeah i got to talk to you
about uh some stuff
keep in mind that uh that that new halo
show coming out what's that oh yeah yeah
you already know the paramount
when the first episode launched they'll
be like you get a free mop
i can see it you're not feeling it why
why didn't you talk to disney plus hbo
max who i'm actually with
netflix but remember they got it was it
was show time right and then they got
sort of bought out it was the whole
thing oh what they need at the end of
the day
at the end of the day i feel you king
but i'm a huge fan of the streaming wars
i want them
[Music]
i downloaded peacock just for halloween
and then got rid of it they got it
you know what's funny king didn't even
do that i just slid in my stuff yeah
this is what i'm saying shout out to
addict for supporting the brother
look my way if there's any other
individuals out there
out here trying to get him from the
stream sherry god salute to the kids
that's all i got no polls this week
because we had to do it forever jason
let's get this super chance to get about
it
all right hold on
back a little bit it wasn't too many
yeah it's not too bad
okay we got first off we have grace
ramsey two dollar super chat thank you
so much please please please say
something yes gordon ramsay's brother
great great friends
yo
there we go gerald magnitude super chat
they have plenty of skins for little man
i i'm sure etsy is rocking out with
skins oh of course i'm not putting
nothing extra because that peel off is
nuts
yeah it leaves it all yeah i'll send
mine to uh you know graphic designer
jonathan b member for 24 months oh
absolutely that's the hold up
salute lord it's happy belated cog they
need to put little man in design lab and
let you do your own customers yeah it's
funny when jason was talking about that
he focused on controllers right but it
popped into my mind like man that just
goes wow with the console that's like
crazy they're going to go
that's going to get you a grip though
you go you cut you pay it again
cost 300 for that gun
you know i don't i don't think so
because okay so
it's going to be eight hundred dollars
you look for the you look at the um xbox
series x the halo version right um
you could probably tack on probably 150
more
to the console
the thing is though as i think the
reason that the price is set like that
is because they mass produce them yeah
but
i don't know you can
but but then if you're limiting it
you're not buying it in mass for
production so you're not saving money on
anything so no i don't i'm talking about
limit the um the the colors and stuff
that they get to choose from okay okay
yeah that's what i'm talking about like
so just start off with like red blue and
green type of thing first and then you
know like a sticker on it i don't know
let's let's let's a little baby steps
let's get an elite controller
first and then
then we'll move to the to the big boy
stuff factual no doubt no doubt so and
we have
a lot more
if microsoft really wants to get into tv
a good acquisition would be all of
warner media
after the discovery deal goes through
yeah
then we have
raiden blade two pound super chat though
it sounds pos is lit i'm even watching
the amino out of the os i've watched
that i watched that completely
completely different
but you're gonna have to clarify what
that means
[Laughter]
the realms police
[Music]
yo i'm done
anyway look amazing show y'all yo y'all
y'all showed out y'all shout out man
this was this is a good one addict talk
to the fine people where can they find
you what you got going on
you can find me on twitter lord addict
iop i will be streaming shinobi tomorrow
uh 5 p.m so uh definitely be looking out
for that appreciate jason ron for coming
on is a great uh great
great time man it's always a fun time
when jason ronaldo comes on
and you know you'll see us next week
i think we might as well just say we're
going to be doing our uh the the vga
crown your lord said yeah i was
wondering what we were going to do we
couldn't do it today
it's
we have a guess
we gonna figure it out we're gonna
figure it out we're gonna figure that
out we're gonna figure that because
yeah because the um
we may have you know we can still do it
we can still do it we just gotta we
gotta we have to make a segment of it
but we can still do it as a later
segment we do have a potential special
guest next week okay
please look at the list
oh
yeah so sorry what five people find you
what you got going on sir you p.o.c
all right
you can find me
online
we could easily still do it but next
week's probably gonna be a long show
yeah it's gonna be long it's gonna be
lower what else we got
um yeah let me get the super chat
shout out to my 49er brother cog answer
my quest fam i don't know what his
question is
i answered the word about the the game
stuff if you talk about
49er stuff you talk about the worst
coach that's what you want i remember
you said something on twitter um i don't
know maybe mike secretary nah we had a
bunch of it yeah
was funny though
he's funny he said i can't coach him you
can't win them
[Laughter]
i did like that i didn't like that
chip kelly was bad he had some bad ones
man
akw has police in the chat cause i said
realm
yeah yeah yeah ran police for sure for
sure but uh split difference oh that one
yeah we got a lot of bad one splint
difference we haven't been terry is the
worst coach ever but he was he would
motivate that all right
yeah i could hopefully find me playing
some halo infinite because tomsula toms
whack sorry
but that's it maybe i'll play some halo
infinite against some actual human
opponents
oh derek erickson okay dennis erickson
okay if if you're scared of the the halo
uh infinite uh pvp
just a gun in halo it's wrong
so yeah
nice just follow them all around the map
and just clean up and get assists you're
gonna be good you'll be good no doubt
lord king we're gonna find people find
you what you got going on sir
first i want to like to thank uh jason
ronald i really do appreciate the time
and and all the energy um and you know
just uh giving us a peek into the mind's
eye of uh a great engineer for sure you
know that that's been there you know for
a very long time watching all the
progression he said he was in the room
with jl and that was crazy yeah we we've
been through some dark days man
um and and i say it we affectionately
because you know a lot of dudes like uh
this is not an xbox game pass but i'm an
xbox dude yeah all right so right
yeah these dudes like don't let [ __ ]
fool you [ __ ] he's on the nintendo uh oh
my god no sega sega i'm a sega kid i'm a
reformer
sega's dead um he's over in nintendo's
camp so he he likes to play the
politically correctness so he's uh he's
fully nintendo
sovereign as well is a real playstation
dude all right so don't worry about it
let's keep let's move let's keep this
moving yeah don't let this fool you so
i'm the only
oh that's what this is oh okay he's the
only real yes we got it now
yeah yeah all of us are frauding it's
kegels
i could show you
my digital library
oh lord look at that
got something on deck so he will run so
i'm gonna keep him here
moving on
i i do i do
love all you guys for coming up listen
i'm gonna tell y'all again
these 10k shirts are limited all right
so january they stopped they won't be
back into production because we'll be on
the 15k and we'll be on the 20k i told
you before the faster we get to 15k and
that's all through to you guys because
you guys got us to 10k yes
share it out i don't care if you go to
your friend and make sure you look at
his phone
and you know
you know you know we we did that this 10
15 20k shirts man you know maybe maybe
the in the future there'll be there'll
be some type of uh giveaway if any if
people have all the shirts
if
you if you well that's later but at 15k
you're going to get a console yeah 50k
would definitely be a guy so yeah
you're getting the console so if it's
little man or whatever the hell y'all
choose yeah we're going to put that up
to a vote um
there's uh i'm working on uh my own show
uh this is kos uh so that stuff is gonna
come up and and on kos we'll be talking
about combat talk and stuff like that
there'll be a live show um working with
a graphic guard okay in the background
on getting all that stuff
weaved up and um attic is going to train
me into the ways of the jedi yeah that
kick channel they've been what that king
i'm i'm the young petty wong uh learning
from the
king show let's go
no doubt salute man
so again the realm let me get one bad
[ __ ] chat great interview and
show thanks for keeping it entertaining
while running dad errands on sunday
happy birthday belated birthday [ __ ] a
little one bad mother love his insights
man yo y'all showed out today again
jason ronaldo the legend
[Music]
what's 20k a car
a new car
yo that would be great
whip
that would be crazy
a nintendo guy but duke on defining duke
and xbox fire kind blasphemy happy
birthday birthday kong and nintendo's
awesome i'm not a nintendo guy i not
listening to king throwing things on me
like that he tried to separate keep xbox
all day himself as some pure xbox men i
want you i want you to listen to him
when he say switch coming to heart
say
anyway yo next week is going to be lit
again salute to everybody also last
thing is t it's pinned on the top um iop
log net swag fifty percent off get your
black friday on put on court iron lords
get a little 15 percent off only one
week only so you only got one week to
rock out also please support lords of
gaming.net we got that exclusive y'all
like i said halo infinite campaign
spoiler free check it out my boy editor
nicholas downey and then we even have a
video at the end of the article with
nicholas and myself talking more about
the game it was thanks to you guys for
us to be able to get the code luckily
for microsoft and support that we get
has been tremendous and again that's all
i got next week is gonna be another one
we look forward to it anything else
anybody else got before we roll out
no
full time i'm out of here
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]